Guten Abend. Vielen Dank.
So, wir haben gehört, es saßen noch nicht alle, sondern es wollten noch Leute Getränke. Wir können den Rest platzieren. Oder es geht doch dann ganz schnell.
Es geht ganz schnell, denke ich. Die Frage wird natürlich sein, guten Abend meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren, liebe Freunde des Podcasts. Die Frage wird sein, was wird hier eigentlich vorwiegend getrunken? Es gibt ja hin und wieder heikle Themen, die wir ansprechen im Podcast. Zum Beispiel das Tempolimit. Dann ist sehr viel los, auch danach. Dann gibt es so Themen, wo man sagt, soll man jetzt noch mal darüber sprechen? Sie sind ja immer heikel. Gaza, Ukraine. Aber wir haben festgestellt, was am wirklich kontroversesten ist, sind unsere unsäglichen Aussagen. Zum Thema Spezi. Wir entschuldigen uns also in aller Form, dass wir annehmen konnten, dass junge Menschen keine Spezi trinken. Also Stefan, ich sagte, ich war in Berlin bei der Buchpremiere. Mir wurde sogar eine Dose Spezi mitgebracht.
Wie alt war derjenige, der es dir mitgebracht hat?
Anfang 20. Aber ich hatte Angst, es zu trinken.
Wir können ja hier eine kurze demografische Umfrage machen. U 30er, Hände hoch. U 20. Okay.
Aber sehr, sehr.
Wer von euch hat in den letzten zehn Tagen mindestens fünf Spezis getrunken? Ah, gar nicht so viel.
Na gut.
Ich habe nämlich Aufklärung bekommen, angeblich. Trinken doch nicht nur Millenials Spezi, weil sie ist aus ihren Kindertagen und eigentlich ist das schon aus dem Markt verdrängt, sondern nein. Ich wollte darauf hingewiesen, es gibt junge Buben. Das sind die Spezisuchtis und die zeigen euch jetzt, wie man Spezis aufmacht. Hört genauer hin. Ich habe an dem Ton jetzt nichts verändert. Sie nennen auch die Folgennummer. Also das ist nicht Folge eins, sondern...
Servus, wer sind die Spezisuchtis?
Ich sage euch verschiedene, wie man Spezis aufmacht.
Part 236, heute mit der Handel.
Prost.
Prost. Part 236, haben sie auf Bayerisch gesagt. Und ich habe noch einen zweiten Witzigen gefunden, denn es ist ja Olympia-Zeit gewesen. Wir haben alle gesehen, was für neue Sportarten jetzt auch olympisch sind. Das qualifiziert sich wahrscheinlich auch.
Ja, was mir an den Spezisucht ist? Ich sage euch verschiedene Wege, wie man Spezis aufmacht. Part 230, heute mit dem Skateboard-Trick von Tom Cat.
Also da wird mit dem Skateboard...
Ist genial! Toll!
Also da wird mit dem Skateboard eine Speziflasche geöffnet. Grandios!
Die jungen Leute, aber ich will noch mal kurz hören. Wir hatten hier eine Kontroverse gerade hinter der Bühne, denn meiner Meinung nach ist das Tempolimit für das Wolfgang auf die Mütze bekommen hat. Auf die Mütze? Immer noch ungeschlagen von dem Thema Spezi.
Ja, vielleicht haben mich dann über Instagram noch mal mehr Nachrichten erreicht in Bezug auf Spezi.
Hat jemand von euch eine Hate-Mail an mich geschrieben?
Normalerweise sind meine Leute ja auch noch mal doch gerne auf dem Gaspedal unterwegs und sagen, endlich hat das mal gesagt, ich würde es mich ja nicht trauen.
Das Gaspedal?
Ja, dass ich dann, vielleicht ist es doch eine Mehrheitsposition am Ende.
Ja, so da wir schon mitten reingesprungen sind, ich möchte euch Wolfgang vorstellen, denn er hat gesagt, heute ist noch kein Frisurenreville.
Ja, was soll ich dazu sagen? So ist es.
Erkläre dich, Wolfgang.
Haare wachsen langsam, relativ langsam. Vor allem, wenn man recht lange Haare hat und die anderen da in diese Richtung gehen müssen, dann dauert es noch ein bisschen, ein ganz wenig Geduld noch. Ich bin ja mal mit dem Ergebnis an sich schon sehr zufrieden.
Ja, sehr gut. Also wir geben uns, wir üben uns in Geduld. Wir wollen uns trotzdem vorstellen, wer ist jetzt dieser Wolfgang? Kann uns jemand Wolfgang vorstellen? Ich schlage vor, wir lassen uns Wolfgang von ihm hier vorstellen.
German names sound so cool and powerful for no reason. Like for example the name Wolfgang. Like let's just take a second and appreciate how cool this name is. Imagine people coming up to you and going like, yo, was's up Wolfgang? Damn, that's badass. Like you're automatically a gang leader if you have this name.
Gang leader.
Super getroffen. Hier sind ja vielleicht noch einige Leute, die dein Demografiebuch gelesen haben und auch noch Kinder planen. Ich fände es auch immer wieder schön, wenn wir auf den Spielplätzen nicht nur die vielen anderen alten Namen hören, sondern vielleicht auch mal Wolfgang, lasst das mit der Schaufel. Also da kann man ja noch drauf hinarbeiten.
Apropos Kinderspielplatz, Wolfgang, wer ist diese Wolfgang? Wir können jetzt überlegen, wenn wir die beiden hier sehen, wer von den beiden gehört zur Wolfgang? Wir überprüfen. Kennst du sie auch?
Ich kenne sie nicht, aber die Frau weiß, worum es geht. Sie weiß, wovon sie spricht. Hervorragend.
Es geht um Karl Marx. Ja. Reicht doch, davon handeln die besten Podcasts. Okay, Wolfgang möchte uns gleich zur Einstimmung noch einen kleinen YouTube-Trend vorstellen, bevor wir zu unseren Gästen kommen. Wir haben nämlich heute Gäste. Es ist auch für uns eine Premiere. Vorher allerdings Frage. 800 Leute haben hier Tickets gekauft. Wir sehen ein paar leere Plätze, es kommen also ungefähr vielleicht 700, durch zwei so 350. Wir wissen also, dass ja, 350 Tage. Wer hat heute Geburtstag? Vier Leute sehe ich.
Okay.
Ein Geburtstagskind möchte ich namentlich aufrufen, Leon. Wo sitzt so Leon? Leon sitzt da drüben. Für Leon habe ich schon vorbereitet, denn während, wie ihr wisst, Wolfgang hat ein neues Buch geschrieben, das aber passend zum Thema nur verkauft wird. Meins gibt's umsonst.
Ist das so eine Ulf-Poschert-Argumentation, die Marxisten die Geld verdienen wollen?
Also das ist für Leon, bitte einmal durchreichen.
Wir Marxisten haben den Kapitalismus verstanden. Ja.
So, wer hat denn noch Geburtstag? War hier noch ein Geburtstagskind? Hier? Ah ja, hier ist noch ein Geburtstagskind. Bitte schön. Einmal durchreichen.
Jetzt werden hier die Bücher verschenkt.
Hier war noch ein Geburtstagskind, da hinten.
Gut.
Das bitte einmal durchreichen. Das Geburtstagskind meldet sich. So, damit sind die Geburtstagskäste bedient. Die anderen vier, die hier noch liegen, kann man bei mir nachher für 100 Euro das Stück kaufen. Ich mache auch Kartenzahlung.
Toll. So viel zum Thema Kapitalismus, künstliche Verknappung etc. Nun ist es ja so, dass YouTube schon seit einiger Zeit populär ist. Wir sprechen ja da schon von 20 Jahren fast. YouTube ist jedenfalls volljährig und wir alle wissen, YouTube begann eigentlich mal damit, dass Leute gesehen haben, da kann ich ja was hochladen, was ich zu Hause aufgenommen habe und dann ist es klar, dass viele erst einmal aus ihrem Alltag etwas erzählten, also eine Art von Tagebuch führten. Vlog nannte man das dann damals primär und so teilten sie ihr Leben dann mit. Das Tagebuch ist ja etwas, was verschlossen bleibt zunächst, wenn man berühmt genug wird, dann später publiziert wird. Und mir ist was Interessantes aufgefallen, nämlich, dass diese uralte YouTube-Tradition jetzt zurückkommt. Also das Tagebuch bei YouTube ist wieder ein Genre, das ungeheuer präsent ist.
Macht ja auch Sinn, seit man alles nur noch mit dem Smartphone macht und nicht mehr mit so einem Stativ und riesiger Spiele-Reflexkamera rumrennen muss.
Ja. Nun gibt es berühmte Tagebücher und es ist ja auch so, manche werden es bei Twitter gesehen haben, dass aus den Tagebüchern berühmter Leute laufend zitiert wird. Hier ein Beispiel. Virginia Woolf schrieb im August, aber vor einigen Jahren natürlich, And so this August is wasted. Ja, da werden manche denken, I feel you. Und ganz legendär sind natürlich die Tagebücher von Thomas Mann, weil sie neben intellektuellen Höhenflügen auch sowas enthalten, morgens gleich wieder einsetzen des Missbefindens. Auch etwas, was wir nachvollziehen können, schrieb Thomas Mann am 25. März 53, oder auch schön ging nach dem Frühstück wieder zur Bette. Haben jetzt manche in den Ferien auch.
Und das kommt jetzt einfach 70 Jahre später immer am Tage, oder? Was ist das für ein Account?
Genau, das ist ein Twitter-Account, der Thomas Mann Daily heißt. Es gibt von ganz vielen Schriftstellern sowas und dort werden dann immer einzelne Sätze gepostet. Und wie du siehst, erleben die dann auch viele Retreats. Noch ein letztes Thomas Mann Zitat. Nervös geschlafen in Folge erotischer Vorstellungen abends. Wer kennt das nicht?
1918.
Ja, hat sich nicht viel geändert. Also die Tagebuchform ist eine lange Tradition. Jetzt in YouTube kommt sie wieder. Wir gucken uns das mal an. Und ich wusste erst nicht, was das ist. Also soll ich wirklich ehrlich sein, wie ich darauf gekommen bin? Also ich hatte so eine ganz verwegene Idee vor etwa acht Wochen. Ich hörte von einem guten Freund, dass der jetzt so tägliche Workouts zuhause macht. Und er schwärmte davon, sagt er, so gut habe er noch nie in Hosen reingepasst und sowas. Und dann hatte ich diese verwegene Idee, ich könnte mich ja auch mal informieren. Und ich fand dann natürlich auch einiges, aber es war meistens sehr anstrengend. Jedenfalls bekommt man dann ja plötzlich ganz andere Dinge auf der YouTube-Oberfläche angezeigt. Bei mir ist ja sonst irgendwelche Vorträge von Adam Toos und sowas. Und plötzlich sah ich dann lauter Fitnessgurus und aber auch solche Kanäle, die 15 Abonnenten hatten und irgendwelche Typen redeten da. Und ich dachte, das habe ich jetzt nicht gesucht. Aber was ist das? Das ist ja doch etwas, was mich neugierig macht.
Hast du dann nervös geschlafen?
Nein, da habe ich überhaupt nicht nervös geschlafen. Aber ich habe mir gedacht, wenn ich jetzt das anklicke, dann sehe ich jetzt jemanden, der zwar ein Tagebuch öffentlich führt, aber nicht diese Idee hat, damit berühmt zu werden. Also das müssen wir jetzt gerade sehen. Also wir sprechen jetzt hier nicht über ein Influencer-Phänomen. Also wir haben jetzt hier nicht mit Leuten zu tun, die eigentlich Coach sind und jetzt alles Mögliche verkaufen wollen, sondern wir sehen jetzt hier ganz normale Typen, irgendwas zwischen 18 und 25, die von ihrem Alltag erzählen. Und wir fragen uns, warum? Wir hören mal rein. Und so geht es einfach weiter.
Aber sehr authentisch, denn es ist wirklich 6 Uhr morgens, es gibt so viel Vocalfrei, man versteht nichts. Vielleicht sollte man zuerst einen halben Liter trinken und dann ein Video aufnehmen.
Oder hier derselbe.
Alright, it's a bit late to be starting a vlog right now, but it's about nine o'clock right now. Just got done with my shoulders and legs. Originally, it was over a week ago now, I had hit my legs and shoulders, but I don't know, I can't remember exactly why, but only, I probably did only less than half the workouts.
Ich frage mich, was ist das für ein Sprechen, dass man in die Öffentlichkeit sich so begibt, aber auch gar nicht das Interesse hat jetzt an Reichweite, sondern es wird getan, damit es getan ist. Das sind also Leute, die jeden Tag so ein Video veröffentlichen und auch so was machen.
Day one, baby, let's go! Das ist der auf der anderen Seite der Leitung, sondern man kommuniziert mit der Maschine und sieht sich eigentlich selbst. Und die sehen sich jetzt wirklich selbst.
Also wie beim Tagebuch schreibt man ja auch nicht jemandem etwas, sondern man schreibt es sich.
Die sehen sich ja selber in ihrer Ego-Kamera. Also sie sehen sich wirklich selber. Und eigentlich reden sie mit sich in einem Jahr oder vorausgedacht, in einem Jahr schauen sie es nochmal an und dann wollen sie ihre Transition sehen.
Und das bedeutet aber auch, das tägliche Drehen verleiht ihrem Tag struktur. Ihre Formwelt und auch nicht auf andere Profile verlinkt. Also zum Beispiel ist es ja bei diesen ganzen Coachings so, dass diese Leute dann einen überall hinbekommen wollen und natürlich auch ihr Instagram und alles anzeigen. Das ist aber bei denen gar nicht der Fall. Also sie machen es nur einfach auf YouTube. Sie haben irgendeinen Namen, aber man kann auch nicht weiter mit ihnen in Kontakt treten, sondern sie machen es, wie du sagst, für sich. Und diese Aufrufzahlen, wenn man sich das hier anguckt, das sind zweistellige Aufrufzahlen, aber sie sind kontinuierlich dabei. Da sind wir schon bei Tag 91, 92 angekommen. Wir hören mal noch ein Beispiel.
Was haben dir die Filmkritiker wie dir gefallen? Die schauen sich alles nur noch in schwarz-weiß an. Die besten Filme der Welt, wenn man die Filmkritiker fragt, kommen alle aus dem schwarz-weiß-Zeit.
Das ist ja so ein Silicon Valley-Trick jetzt, dass viele das Smartphone ganz auf schwarz-weiß stellen, damit sie nicht mehr so angefixt werden von dieser Dopamin-Kultur, auf die wir wahrscheinlich heute auch noch zu sprechen kommen. Aber der duktus, in dem es vorgetragen wird, ist ja interessant. Keine Ahnung, wie alt er ist, 19 Jahre oder so. Aber er hat sich seine Stimme angehöhnt. Also ich finde es krass, dass es jetzt auch ganz viele YouTube-Videos gibt, die einem erklären, wie man die Stimme nach unten drücken kann.
Ja, das stimmt. Ich glaube, du hast auch so ein bisschen Antipathie, weil du hier keine Modesachen beurteilen kannst.
Möglicherweise. Wir hören weiter. Ich dokumentiere, dass ich laufe.
Hier werden eigentlich zwei aktuelle Trends miteinander verbunden. Ein bisschen. Und dann diese Idee von, um dich zu motivieren, sage einem besten Freund Bescheid, der dich auf die Reise mitnimmt und sogar antreibt. Und da ja heute jeder erst mal self-love-mäßig selbst der beste Freund ist, ist er einfach mit sich. Früher, es gab doch mal die Zeit, die Telefone kamen gerade und man hat gedacht, die Leute sind im Selbstgespräch, das ist ja komisch, öffentlich zu telefonieren, heute ganz normal. Stellt mal vor, die werden damals mit zum Spiegel in der Hand rumgelaufen, um sich selbst die ganze Zeit zu sehen, wie sehe ich aus, wie sehe ich aus. Heute mit dem Smartphone denken wir so, ja ganz normal.
Und der ist ja tatsächlich im Selbstgespräch, da niemand diese Videos guckt.
Ja, aber?
Also außer wir jetzt, er hat jetzt mehr Zuschauer heute Abend, als in seiner ganzen Kanalhistorie.
Aber ich will es nochmal betonen, er ist im Selbstgespräch mit sich in ein oder zehn Jahren, also das macht er für sein Eignis zurückschauen, wahrscheinlich.
Führt jemand ein Videotagebuch bei YouTube? Vielleicht habe ich ja schon jemanden entdeckt. Nein. Könnte also ein Trend werden noch hier dann, ist jedenfalls bei YouTube schon groß. Es muss auch gar kein Inhalt her sein, man sagt einfach nur, wie war der Tag?
Ja, ich habe die Clips vorher nicht gesehen. Hier auf der Bühne höre ich die nur sehr hallend und so murmelnd. Also ich höre eigentlich nur an eurem Reaktion, ob er was Witziges gesagt hat. Bisher schlagen die sich aber ganz gut, finde ich. Es hat ein bisschen was ausgelöst.
Er jedenfalls berichtet, egal wo er ist, dann einfach von dem, was er tagsüber gemacht hat. Und schneidet das auch noch so zusammen? Also ist aufgestanden, was gegessen? Time with family, nächstes? Oder wenn er gerade im Auto sitzt?
Ja, gut, leckte mit meinem Freund.
Ja, war gut.
Ist aber ein bisschen müde noch. Oder wieder. Hier sehen wir nochmal seinen Kanal. Auch da sehen wir 15 Aufrufe, 29 Aufrufe, 47 Aufrufe. Aber es wird laufend bespielt. Das heißt, wir haben eine Generation, also nicht eine Generation vielleicht gleich, aber wir haben doch sehr viele Leute, die ein Selbstgespräch führen, aber das ja nicht auf ihrem Smartphone belassen, sondern ist schon der Öffentlichkeit übergeben. Nicht mit dem Wunsch, berühmt zu werden, aber als sei da so der YouTube-Gott, dem man es sagen muss. Also man muss es ja schon mitkriegen. Das ist der große andere.
Ja, doch, der große andere. Ich will aber nochmal betonen, da wir beim letzten Mal die amerikanischen Wahlkampf-Fortschritte uns angeschaut haben und du dann meintest, ja, aber irgendwann muss man auch über Inhalte reden. Und ich sagte nein, und wir werden das jetzt im August nochmal vertiefen.
Oh Gott.
Das sind nicht die einzigen, die ohne Inhalt YouTube füllen. Also wenn ich meinen eigenen Medienkonsum mir gerade anschaue, jeden Morgen setze ich mich hin und gucke mir Colbert und Daily Show an, was alles nicht gesagt wurde auf amerikanischen Debattenbühnen oder wo auch immer. Und es ist halt einfach unterhaltsam.
Aber das ist ja noch nicht mal unterhaltsam. Das ist ja das Interessante. Das ist ja so ein Unterschied zu den Influencern oder zu den anderen YouTubern, dass die ja alles dafür tun, geliebt zu werden, geliked zu werden und was weiß ich. Das tun die ja gerade nicht, sondern die machen einfach das Smartphone an, schlechte Beleuchtung, schlechter Ton, zu sagen haben sie auch nichts, aber sie drehen es. Und das ist ein neuer Umgang jedenfalls mit YouTube. Möglicherweise haben wir also nicht mehr nur diese Leute, die berühmt werden wollen auf YouTube, sondern YouTube ist einfach eine normale Ausdrucksplattform geworden für das alle alltägliche und man hat dadurch so ein öffentliches Diary, das einem eine struktur gibt, die sonst ein bisschen fehlt, wenn gleich mir auch nicht klar ist, welche struktur das ist, dass man jetzt noch das Essen fertig machen muss für morgen.
Ja, aber das ist doch eigentlich, ich meine zuerst keine Inhalte und jetzt nicht mal mehr Methode. Das heißt ja, das ist einfach nur unreflektierter Alltag. Und einer der größten Flocker, Casey Neistat, hat ja damals die Beam-App erfunden, die er in dem Moment aufnimmt, in dem der Annäherungs-Sensor merkt, ich bin gerade nah dran. Also der Auslöser war, du hältst es an deine Brust und das Smartphone sieht nur, was du siehst, aber du kannst gerade nicht aufs Display schauen. Und das ist ja im Grunde auch so ein, wir sind halt einfach irgendwo, be real, ja wir machen einfach ein be real und das war's. Damit sieht man, wo das Smartphone jetzt überall ist, überall.
Sehr viele dieser Videos sind auch relativ lang, 10, 20, 30 Minuten. Ich habe dann aber auch jemanden entdeckt, der relativ kurz unterwegs ist. Also wir hören uns jetzt so einen kompletten Beitrag von ihm an.
What up, today is Saturday, May 18th, 2024. I'm gonna make this a quick video, I wanna go to bed. I woke up at around 11, had work at 1. A good day at work, it was really boring. Because you weren't allowed to have carts out because of the rain. No carts were allowed on the course and the range was also closed, the driving range. So that means not many people showed up. There was two people on for the shift. I just hand picked the range, the balls that were plugged.
Was mir aufgefallen ist, ist, dass sehr viele dieser jungen Männer, die das machen, arbeiten und das heißt, sie sind jung und gehen also nicht nur ins Fitnessstudio. Nein, sie laufen nicht jetzt in einer Uni-Karriere hinterher, sondern sie scheinen also in der normalen Arbeit zu sein und haben relativ anstrengende Tage, was auch erklärt, warum die sie oft sehr müde am Abend klingen, sind dann vielleicht noch im Fitnessstudio gewesen und jetzt ist noch ein bisschen Netflix und das war es dann. Interessant ist, dass sie gar nicht über irgendwas aus ihrer Freizeit berichten, außer wenn sie mal im Gym waren. Aber es gibt nicht, dass sie über einen Film reden, den sie gesehen haben, geschweige dann ein Buch gelesen haben oder sonst eine kulturelle Aktivität. Das ist also tatsächlich auch so ein erwerbstätigen Leben, das sehr viel wirklich Realität dann widerspiegelt, wie sie ist. Also Leute, die in ziemlich anstrengenden Jobs sind, die möglicherweise nicht besonders inhaltlich befriedigend sind, die dann, wie ihr sagt, Geld eingebracht haben. Aber dann verlebt man sehr anstrengende, aber irgendwo auch sehr langweilige Tage, meldet sich noch mal kurz zu Wort und geht dann wieder schlafen, auftanken für den nächsten Tag. Also diese Wirklichkeit ist eine, die ja sonst fast gar nicht präsent ist bei YouTube, weil man eigentlich nur so Montes hat, die den ganzen Tag Eistee sauchen und Millionär dabei werden. Und das ist schon interessant, dass jetzt hier so eine Art Working Class sich zu Wort meldet.
Wir können ja sagen, die haben jetzt eine Methode gefunden, sich selbst darzustellen und damit auch ein bisschen selbst zu verwirklichen, das also nicht in diese Richtung abdrifte, die bedienen wir uns dann immer lustig machen. Und unser Professor Podcast hier aus der Hörerschaft, Moritz Kleng, hat ja damals jeden Tag gepodcastet, 2018. Da sind dann auch im Sommer diese Monate, war heute wieder beim Hartz-IV-Amt, weil mich ja der Staat im Sommer nicht beschäftigt, wenn ich an der Uni bin und so weiter. Und dann hat er das ein Jahr später kommentiert, transkribiert und ausgedruckt. Als Dissertation eingereicht, ist heute Professor in Mannheim. Wer weiß, in welche Richtung diese jungen Männer noch gehen.
Wir hören uns noch einen letzten Clip an, um nochmal diese Alltäglichkeit zu bekommen. Und die ist tatsächlich jetzt nicht, um das auszustellen, dass das alles so lustig ist, sondern ich glaube tatsächlich, wo wir sehr viel darüber geredet haben, auch in Bezug auf Scott Galloway, so eine gewisse Verzweiflung, was ist eigentlich los? Und geht mein erwerbstätigen Leben jetzt doch so hamsterradähnlich immer weiter? Gibt es Möglichkeiten auszubrechen? Hier, glaube ich, haben wir es mit ganz vielen Leuten zu tun, die nicht an die große Erfolgsstrategie glauben, sonst würden sie ja selbst auch vielleicht schon in so einer Coaching-Richtung reden oder denken oder zumindest ähnlich agieren, sondern es sind schon Leute, die sehr in diesem sogenannten Hamsterrad sind, die jetzt aber daraus mal so kurz berichten, um vielleicht selbst in dieser Monotonie nochmal so eine eigene struktur herzustellen.
What up? Today's Friday, July 26th, 2024. I woke up. I was late even though I went to bed early. Woke up at like 11, played a few holes, played a little bit more than nine. Didn't really play that well. That's all right, I played with my dad. It was fun. Finished up golf, went to work. I picked the range and closed. It was all right. And then came back, had dinner. About to go to bed. That's all I got for today. And yeah, thank you.
Das war's.
Ja, hier hätte noch eine gute Pointe gepasst. Es gibt so ein lustiges Video von so einem amerikanischen Dad, der eine Tochter hat. Der sich also die Männerwelt genau anschaut, die 17 Jahre alt ist. Und der festgestellt hat, dass wirklich jeder heute die Alpaka-Frisur trägt. Und die auch alle.
Ist das die Alpaka-Frisur?
Man hat diese wirbelnden Haare nochmal an der Stirn.
Ah, okay. Das kannte ich gar nicht. Aber das ist keine Etka. Das ist wieder was anderes.
Ja, so, wir kriegen gerade noch was zu trinken und können deswegen schon mal sagen, was wir heute eigentlich vorhaben. Denn wir wurden schon gefragt, ist heute künstliche Intelligenz dran? Und ich sagte nein, natürlich nicht. Denn wir haben heute andere Themen und uns auch Gäste dazu eingeladen. Denn ich bin in beiden Themen Newbie, um nicht zu sagen, oder Newbie, in dem ein Thema gar nicht präsent eigentlich. Ich lese keine Romane. Ich weiß nicht genau, warum. Jedes Mal, wenn mich jemand fragt, was sollte ich lesen, sage ich Thomas Mann. Natürlich pflichtbewusst. Nein, irgendwas fällt mir dann schon immer schon ein. Aber ich lese eigentlich nie so. Und nur durch dich bin ich zur Oper gekommen. Das ist also die zweite große Marotte, dass ich jetzt zu Hause so einen Stapel, das war ja eine der ersten Empfehlungen, Wolfgang geht also in die Oper und stürmt sofort zu diesem Schalter, wo man seinen Programmheft kauft. Und ich dachte mir so, muss ich jetzt auch noch was lesen oder so? Nein, es ist natürlich nur als Andenken gedacht.
Nein, das Programmheft ist an sich schon dazu da, dass man es liest.
Es stehen Worte drin.
Zum Beispiel vor der Vorstellung, in der Pause, danach noch einmal.
Ja, aber bei mir zu Hause stellt sich das raus.
Und gerade die Frankfurter Hefte sind wirklich sehr gut gemacht. Da hast du so kleine Kompendien zu der jeweiligen Oper.
Ja, das werden wir gleich besprechen. Ich habe jedenfalls zu Hause jetzt so eine Stapel aus 22 Programmheften und mir fehlt eins zu Ulisse, oder Ulis, Ulis heißt sie, meine erste Oper, was ein bisschen schade ist. Aber es entsteht so langsam so ein, und jetzt frage ich mich, du warst in so vielen Opern, ne? Hast du so einen extra Raum eigentlich für diese Programmhefte, oder?
Ich habe einige Regalmeter, die mit Programmheften bestückt sind und auch sortiert sind. Das heißt, wenn jetzt jemand sagt Don Giovanni, dann kann ich gucken M. Mozart, Don Giovanni, und dann kann ich sehen, wo ich das überall geguckt habe und kann auch in diesen Programmheften nochmal was nachlesen. Also sie sind ganz toll.
Ja, sie sind ja toll. Ich habe auch schon mal reingeschaut in eins. Nein, ich splitter schon durch, keine Sorge. Man hat ja auch in der Pause immer relativ viel Zeit, wenn man sich nicht noch so einen Tisch bestellt, wo man so Häppchen und so weiter. Häppchen für vier Euro kauft.
Ja, das ältere Semester geht vor allem zum Essen in die Oper, ist uns aufgefallen. Auch in Windeseile spachteln sie also mehrere Platten hinein.
Man kommt immer raus, sieht diese Berge da und dann sitzen da so zwei Omis und nach zehn Minuten ist alles weg. So, wir haben jedenfalls gedacht, wir reden heute über die Oper und über Bücher mit euch. Wir haben also Gäste da und ich möchte euch für die Oper und unseren ersten vorstellen, einen Juristen, Torsten Kutschke. Er ist eingetroffen, er war eben noch beim Fußball, ist aber rechtzeitig hier angekommen. Torsten ist Jurist, wie gesagt, und mir eigentlich bekannt gewesen über meine Freundin als DFV-Host hier, wo er vor allem mit Kommunikation und Recht und lauter solchen Fragen zu tun hat. Aber er ist auch Chef, sage ich jetzt einfach mal, du kannst uns dann gleich aufklären, vom Theaterverlag. Der Theaterverlag hat, glaube ich, vier Publikationen. Eine zur Theater, eine zur Oper, eine zum Tanz und dann nochmal eine zur ganzen Technik, mit der man so zu tun hat, wenn man nicht Publikum ist. Und erst dann sieht man ja, was da alles zu tun ist. Und damit ist er Herausgeber oder Chef jedenfalls dieser Opernwelt, dieser Zeitschrift, die es gibt, die immer mal wieder die Kritiker fragt, welches ist denn das beste Opernhaus des Jahres? Und da wurde jetzt sechsmal in Folge das Frankfurter, die Frankfurter Oper ausgewählt. Also wer zu Gast in Frankfurt ist, wer ist zu Gast in Frankfurt? Sehr viele. Es ist ja gerade Sommerpause. Wer hat vor, mal hier in Frankfurt, also überhaupt, also geht mal die Frankfurter Oper, sie scheint sehr gut zu sein. Ich kann das jedenfalls bestätigen. Und damit holen wir zuerst Torsten Kutschke auf die Bühne und Wolfgang sagt uns, wer der zweite Gast ist.
Herzlich willkommen. Als zweiten Gast begrüßen wir auf dieser Bühne den ehemaligen Operntramatogen vom Staatstheater Wiesbaden. Er ist nun der persönliche Referent des Frankfurter Opernintendanten und er selbst ist auch Musiker. Er stammt auch aus einer Musikerfamilie. Die Mutter ist Opernsängerin, spezialisiert auf Wagner. Also eigentlich ist dann der Werdegang doch klar oder auch nicht. Das werden wir ihn auch fragen. Herzlich willkommen, Constantin Mende. Stefan hat gleich diese Idee gehabt für den Live-Podcast, dass wir ein bisschen über die Oper sprechen sollen. Und Stefan ist ja da noch ein Newcomer, aber Feuer und Flamme wird nicht so passen.
Ab wann bin ich dann kein Newcomer mehr? Ich bin jetzt 22 Opern. Ich fühle mich auch selber über noch als Newcomer. Also keine Sorge, das war schon richtig von Wolfgang.
Also du musst, glaube ich, jetzt so langsam diesen Weg finden und ich weiß, das wird dir unbehagen bereiten, durch die Lande zu reisen, zu allen möglichen Inszenierungen und zu sagen, die Butterfly hat mir gar nicht gefallen in Darmstadt. Dann gehst du weiter nach Dresden, dann Hannover, dann aber auch die Sommerferien fallen eher aus. Also nicht mehr Texel, sondern dann ist Salzburg, Bayreuth usw. angesagt. Also da musst du natürlich noch einiges tun.
Stimmt das. Wie viel reist ihr für die Oper, Torsten? Wie viel bist du unterwegs in Deutschland? Welche Opernhäuser kennst du oder noch nicht?
Ich sehe 200 Aufführungen im Jahr, nicht nur Oper, aber auch Theater und Ballett und bin eigentlich ein bis zwei Tage die Woche überhaupt nur in Frankfurt bzw. ein Wochenende im Monat.
Also du kommst sowieso rum und dann verbindest du jede Reise mit einer Oper. Also Wolfgang reist ja immer nur mit Opern oder sonstigen Kulturprogrammen.
Genau, also Schauspiel wenig, aber Museen noch und Konzerte natürlich. Aber die Oper ist das, was mich am meisten zum Reisen bringt, wenn es dann nicht jetzt beruflich Vorträge oder sowas sind. Ja, aber Constantin reist auch viel.
Ich reise auch viel. Ja, genau. Vielleicht nicht ganz so viel wie du, Torsten. Also das ist ja wirklich schon eine sehr stolze Nummer mit 200 Opern Vorstellungen im Jahr. Und das schaffe ich nicht. Ich muss auch noch ein bisschen arbeiten.
Das ist für mich Arbeit.
Ja, ich weiß. Genau. Nein, aber ich bin ja auch daran. Nein, aber ich bin ja auch dran beteiligt, irgendwie die selbst zu machen, die opernproduktion. Und ich schaue deswegen natürlich auch immer opernproduktionen bei meinem Haus. Soll ich die jetzt mitzählen oder nicht? Das ist die Frage. Aber sonst denke ich schon, dass ich so ein bis zwei Vorstellungen irgendwo sehe in Deutschland die Woche, denke ich mal. Also ich fahre eigentlich jede Woche irgendwo hin, um was zu sehen.
Sammelst du noch Programmhefte?
Ja, selbstverständlich.
Aber braucht man da nicht wirklich langsam extra Räume dafür? Die sind ja schon so einen halben Zentimeter dick.
Ich habe jetzt noch Regale angekauft, also angebaut an der Seite.
Wir haben übrigens Opernwelten, die hier ins Gebäude geschickt worden, Mustafa. Also wir wissen nachher, wo die Opernwelten, die hier hergeschickt wurden, liegen.
Ja, vielleicht kann Torsten ein bisschen was erzählen. An wen richtet sich diese Opernwelt? Das ist jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht für die Einsteiger direkt die Publikation, zu der man greift oder was ist die Klientel dieser sehr hochwertig produzierten Zeitschrift?
Ich habe natürlich ein bisschen Propagandamaterial mitgebracht. Also so sieht das Ganze aus. Die Post freut sich immer, weil es ein Sonderformat ist, also nicht DIN A4, sondern ein bisschen größer. Das sorgt dafür, wenn wir es einfach verkleinern würden, ich glaube mal, das Ergebnis des Verlages würde sich verdoppeln. Zum einen lesen es wirklich die Häuser natürlich selber, weil die wissen wollen, was wir gerade dazu schreiben, was andere Institutionen veröffentlicht haben. Und es gibt ausreichend Freaks, die einfach sowieso ähnlich wie ich, aber einfach nur aus dann wirklich privatem Interesse, oftmals schon im Rentenalter vermutlich, aber unterwegs sind, um einfach gerade Wagnerstücke, gerade in den Ringlern, die Belungen und so alles, möglichst überall zu sehen, wo das Ganze aufgeführt wird. Und das sorgt dafür, dass plötzlich Oldenburg, also das ist ein ziemlich anspruchsvolles Stück. Bayreuth hat es immer und in Bayreuth gibt es ein ziemlich viele Buß und das ist also sowieso nur die Freaks, die sich das Ganze anschauen, an vier Abenden, auch nicht hintereinander, sondern das sind noch mal ein paar Tage zwischendurch. Es ist nicht nur schwierig, für Bayreuth Karten zu kriegen. Das nächste Schwierige ist in Bayreuth, was ein bisschen größeres Dorf ist, ein Hotelzimmer zu kriegen und das sind dann auch schon zu Preisen, die man sich leisten können muss.
Gibt es da keine Zeltstätte, das ist mal wie in so einem Festival.
Schön.
Kein Kommentar.
Ich wollte noch sagen, ich habe bevor ich wirklich in Amthor und Würden war, die Opernwelt auch schon privat abonniert gehabt, Theater heute auch schon und habe einfach daraus viele Inspirationen gezogen. Ich bin dann auch nach Cottbus, nach Halle an der Saale, nach Meiningen gefahren, um mir einfach die Aufführung anzuschauen.
Ja, Meiningen war ich auch kürzlich, um Wagner's Die Feen mir anzusehen, denn das wird selten gegeben. Constantin, wie ist das jetzt? Haben wir eine Fachpublikation, von der wir hören, das ist für die absoluten Fans, aber auch für die Häuser selbst interessant. Ist das für euch ganz wichtig, was die Kritiker schreiben oder sagt ihr, gerade in Frankfurt ist es eh immer voll?
Also wir gucken natürlich in die Opernwelt, was die Kritiker dort sagen. Man kennt ja inzwischen auch die Kritiker und kann oft auch so ein bisschen einschätzen, was die über eine produktion denken. Das heißt aber nicht, dass wir jetzt eine produktion extra so produzieren, dass es der Opernwelt gefällt. Und wir hatten jetzt Glück, dass wir eben wirklich oft in Folge auch ausgezeichnet wurden und dass viele Kritiker, die für die Opernwelt schreiben und befragt wurden von der Opernwelt, dann eben auch wirklich auch Frankfurt als so ein Zentrum ansehen. Wir machen aber natürlich auch, wenn Frankfurt jetzt international so wahrgenommen wird als so ein Haus, was eine ziemlich große Ausstrahlung hat, machen wir eigentlich, würde ich mal sagen, Oper für die Stadt, also Oper für die Menschen, die auch hier wohnen. Und ich glaube nicht, dass da so Überlegungen so die Rolle spielen, dass wir sagen, wir müssen jetzt unbedingt diesen Titel nochmal bekommen und jetzt müssen wir nochmal diese Oper ins Programm nehmen. Aber irgendwie hat das da in den vergangenen Jahren ja immer sehr gut trotzdem geklappt.
Die nächste Ausgabe, ganz kurz, des Jahrbuches der Opernwelt, wo dann wieder, also wir befragen um die 50 Kritiker und Kritikerinnen, deutschlandweit, Österreich und Schweiz auch, was denn das Opernhaus des Jahres ist. Und dieses Opernhaus des Jahres ist dann wirklich so der branchen Ausgabe, wenn man das will. Und ich weiß übrigens schon, wer in diesem Jahr gewonnen hat, aber ich sag's dir nicht.
Bist ja aber sehr gespannt.
Ja, weil das ist ja auch eine der Fragen, weil du das jetzt so sagst, Constantin, wir produzieren nicht so, dass die Opernwelt uns auszeichnet. Wüsste man denn, wie man produzieren sollte, damit, weil ich mein, bei vielen Genres ist das klar. Also in Hollywood weiß man, wie man Publikumserfolg macht. In die Bücherwelt rückt das auch langsam ein, nachdem man so Publikumserfolge metergenau bis wohin wird gelesen. Und dann guckt man sich an, was die Highlights sind und baut daraus halt, synthetisiert so das nächste Buch. Aber bei der Oper, ist so mein Eindruck, gehen eigentlich alle mit so viel Dreifachreflektion irgendwie rein und suchen dann irgendwelche Easter Eggs oder was auch immer, dass man gar nicht genau weiß. Also man müsste erstmal wissen, welcher Kritiker sitzt denn heute mit drin, was hat der für Vorlieben, sind das auch heute noch seine Vorlieben, hat er irgendwelche Brüche, sind seine ästhetischen, was auch immer Rezeptionsgeschichte. Also ich glaube, die Oper entzieht sich komplett eigentlich so eine Idee von, ja wir könnten ja auch mal für so gezielt irgendwas machen, sondern man versucht halt...
Es gibt schon immer so Moden auch in der Oper, also in der Regissprache und so weiter. Und da würde ich aber jetzt nicht unbedingt sagen, dass die Opernwelt dann immer nur die Mode abbildet. Das ist jetzt ein verstecktes Kompliment irgendwie. Dafür sind die Kritiker, die für die Opernwelt schreiben, dann doch irgendwie alle sehr eigene Persönlichkeiten. Und das ist dann nicht so durchsichtig, dass man sagen kann, ne, wir wollen jetzt unbedingt damit der und der Kritiker das gut findet. Machen wir das jetzt so? Also man weiß ja auch nicht vorher, wer das dann rezipiert und so weiter.
So, jetzt hat Wolfgang gesagt, ich sollte mir schon mal ein Stück, ein Werk, das ich schon kenne, vielleicht von einer anderen Inszenierung woanders anschauen. Was ja bedeutet, ich müsste dann mal Frankfurt verlassen. Die Frankfurter Oper ist also für mich mitten in der Stadt, dieser komische architektonisch jetzt nicht herausragende Kasten. Jetzt hast Torsten, du mir geschrieben, ich bin gerade auf dem Weg nach Bayreuth. Ich habe deswegen mal für alle die, wie ich, wenn ihr so denkt wie ich, so Bayreuth, keine Ahnung, das ist halt irgendwas mit Wagner. Das hier ist das Operngebäude in Bayreuth. Ich hab mal die kitschige Instagram-Musik drin gelassen.
Ja Moment.
Die Musik, die Musik, sorry. Ja Stefan, jetzt, jetzt werde ich aufgeklärt.
Das ist nicht das Bayreuther Festspielhaus gewesen.
Nein, ja siehste, klär mich auf. Was ist das denn? Das ist das Barocktheater. Ach, die Oper findet gar nicht da statt.
Nein, nein, dort finden, da kann man keinen Wagner drin spielen. Das ist fast ausgeschlossen. Das Festspielhaus, das wurde ja von König Ludwig Wagner zu Ehren errichtet und das ist ja nur für Wagner-Opern vorgesehen. Da ist der Orchesterkragen ganz tief. Der Bau ist so schlicht, so heißt es immer, dass man dachte, da ist irgendwie eine alte Fabrik, die hat man deswegen nicht bombardiert. Also ist im Krieg auch nichts passiert. Dieses Bayreuther Festspielhaus ist ganz schlicht. Man hat sehr harte Stühle, aber deshalb eine tolle Akustik. Das ist das historische Barocktheater, das ein unglaublich faszinierender Ort ist. Ich habe da leider noch nichts drin gehört, aber ich war schon dort drin. Sollte man sich unbedingt mal ansehen, aber da gibt es dann auch ab September wieder Barockopern, aber dann ist man eher so Händel oder so unterwegs.
Also das ist ohne Orchestergraben wirklich ein Theater im Sinne von?
Mit Orchestergraben. Ich weiß nicht, wie tief der jetzt da ist. Ihr wart wahrscheinlich schon mal da.
Na gut, dann sollte ich vielleicht doch mal reisen, denn mir ist eine Sache aufgefallen. Jetzt mal ohne Ton, weil das läuft ein paar Minuten. Ich habe auf YouTube mal geguckt, Opernhäuser der Welt. Und jetzt zeichnen sich ja Stadtkerne tatsächlich durch so ein paar architektonische Sachen über Jahrhunderte aus. Kirchen zum Beispiel. Universitäten. Oder eben Opernhäuser. Und diese Opernhäuser haben eine erstaunliche Resilienz. Also da wurden vor 300 Jahren Opern gespielt. Und da werden heute Opern gespielt. Wenn man heute eine Kirche sieht, naja, also wenn man durch die neuen Bundesländer fährt oder so, da sind fast alle entweiht. Die sind quasi komplett ungewidmet worden. Universitäten, ja, es gibt noch so das eine Hauptgebäude im Zentrum, aber der Rest findet auf irgendeinem Hügel statt, wo man noch so ein paar Hörsaale hingesetzt hat. Und diese Opern haben so eine erstaunliche Markierungskonsistenz über die Jahrhunderte. Egal welcher Medienwandel, egal welche demografische Explosion von Bevölkerung oder so, Opern sind einfach immer Opern geblieben. Eines der faszinierenden Phänomene, über das ich jetzt so gestolpert bin.
Da stellt sich die Frage, woran liegt das? Das ist ja eigentlich das, woran auch die katholische Kirche arbeitet, aber dann doch immer wieder so Kontinuitätsbrüche hat. Liegt das, was würdet ihr sagen, jetzt wo es die Oper seit über 400 Jahren gibt, daran, dass wirklich die Repertoirepflege an oberster Stelle steht, dass die Kanonpflege so enorm wichtig ist und man immer nur leicht aufbricht ins Moderne oder Vergessenes hervorholt?
Na ja, man hat ja nicht immer nur alte Stücke gespielt, wie es heute oft so ist. Also heute ist es wieder ein bisschen anders, aber lange Zeit jetzt im 20. Jahrhundert hat man wirklich sehr viele Stücke gespielt, die echt schon ein paar hundert Jahre alt sind. Und das war aber dann hundert Jahre davor nochmal wiederum ganz anders. Also davor hat man ganz oft wirklich nur neue Stücke gespielt. Also da kann es jetzt nicht unbedingt darin liegen, dass man sagt, da wird der Kanon gepflegt, um das aufrechtzuerhalten. Aber ich würde sagen, dass Oper an sich natürlich erstmal als Kunstform eine unglaubliche Faszination ausübt auf Menschen. Und das hat er jetzt so repräsentativ angefangen, die ganze Operngeschichte, also Anfang des 17. Jahrhunderts, Ende des 16. Jahrhunderts, wo man so bei Hochzeiten zum Beispiel solche Veranstaltungen gemacht hat, die schon an die Oper erinnert haben. Und da war das Repräsentation. Aber dann kam das schon sehr bald, dass die dann den Städten gesagt haben, die Bürger, wir wollen das eigentlich auch haben. Und da, finde ich, sieht man schon dran, da gab es irgendwann eine große Oper, zum Beispiel in Deutschland, in Hamburg am Gänsemarkt. Das heißt, die ganzen bürgerlichen Städte, die wollten dann auch alle Oper haben. Also irgendwie hat das schon von Beginn an echt alle angesprochen.
Und wenn diese Opernhäuser nicht irgendwann zwischendurch mal abgebrannt sind, was öfters mal passiert ist, dann stehen die einfach unter Denkmalschutz und es ist gar nicht mal so leicht, die wieder wegzukriegen.
Also in Frankfurt haben wir ja die Diskussion Neues Opernhaus. Und die Diskussion ist ja vor allem darüber geführt worden, ob man das alte renoviert oder neues baut. Das sind jahrzehntelange Projekte. Also die Planung sind unendlich lang mehr als eine Biografie. Eine, wenn man so sagen, die Oper kommt, dann kann es durchaus mal die ganze Erwerbsbiografie dauern, bis du in Hausnähe bist. Und egal, welchen Plan man nimmt, der Kostenposten war beides mal 1,7 Milliarden. Also das alte Gebäude renovieren oder das neue Bauen sind wirklich Milliarden Werte, was ich unglaublich finde. So, wir wollen mal kurz reinhören, denn Wolfgang und ich, wir haben ja auch schon mal darüber gesprochen, dass wir im selben Gebäude eine Tür weiter im Schauspiel waren in Frankfurt. Einmal und wir sind während der Veranstaltung rausgegangen, weil es einfach nicht gut war. Und das ist eigentlich ganz interessant, denn man erwartet ja auf der Bühne das, was los ist. Und das, was los ist, stellt man vor allem darüber her, dass man ein Spiel hat und Lautstärke. So, in der Oper kann es sehr laut sein. Also in Frankfurt wird typischerweise ohne Mikrofonierung gespielt oder sie ist gut versteckt, aber da sitzen tausend Leute.
Das ist ja die Kunst, dass man wirklich tausend Leute oder 1300 Leute irgendwie erreichen kann, ohne irgendwelche technische Verstärkung.
Also wir hören gleich Nicholas Brownlee mal kurz, sofern das über Instagram Videos geht. Ich finde, es geht schon ganz schön weit dafür, dass man so einen Eindruck bekommt. Aber wir hören jetzt einmal den Trailer, den die Oper immer macht, wie ich finde, viel zu kurz. Man sieht nicht so wirklich, was jetzt in der Oper vor sich geht. Aber wir haben ja mal 40 Sekunden aus einer Oper, die ich aus der letzten Spielzeit sehr gut fand, Marta. Deshalb ich auch zweimal drin war. Das klingt dann so. So, das Stück ist schon älter.
Dann ist Stefan ganz glücklich, also mindestens 15 Kostümwechsel, großer Chor, viel Laut.
Und ein Schlager.
Und noch ein Schlager, letzte Rose.
Genau, ist also nicht nur bei mir sehr beliebt. In diesem Trailer sind Schauspieler, die spielen heute gar nicht mehr. Also man kriegt heute schon wieder ein neues Ensemble. Und jetzt mal im Vergleich. Es ist, ihr seht jetzt eine Theaterbühne, ein Schauspieler, den ich wirklich über alle Maßen mag. Und trotzdem finde ich es unerträglich. Man will irgendwie nicht angeschrien werden. Man will auch nicht, dass auf Reihe eins irgendwie die Spucke runter regnet oder was auch immer. Und trotzdem sucht man Expressivität. So und in der Oper wird einfach gesungen. Und diesen Unterschied, ich wundere mich jedes Mal mehr darüber, wie fesselnd das sein kann, wenn eine Sopranistin vorne am Bühnenrand steht und einfach jedes Ohr beschallt und trotzdem nervt es nicht. Und dieses Sprechtheater, Schreiteater ist eigentlich immer gleich blöd irgendwie, finde ich mittlerweile.
Nun kann man das ja nicht so absolut setzen. Also ich war natürlich auch schon sehr häufig im Schauspiel, wo es anders ging. Und es gibt ja Gutes zu sehen. Ich würde aber erst mal festhalten, dass die Enttäuschung, wenn man im Schauspiel sitzt, generell größer sein kann als in der Oper. Dass da mal eine Inszenierung nicht so toll ist oder das Orchester ein bisschen hinterherhängt, weil der Dirigent dann doch schon zu alt ist oder so. Das kann passieren, aber es ist nicht der ganze Abend miserabel selten. Bei einer schlechten Inszenierung im Schauspiel kann es natürlich sehr schnell sein, dass es dann verhunzt ist. Also wenn die Schauspieler angewiesen bekommen, drei Stunden durchzubrüllen, dann ist auch der schönste Shakespeare-Text nicht mehr zu retten. So haben wir es ja erlebt. Da ist also die Enttäuschung tendenziell größer, aber dennoch können natürlich diese Momente des Sprechens– auch das Exzaltierte und auch das Laute– natürlich sehr eindringlich sein, wenn man es bewusst einsetzt. Aber ich habe schon den Eindruck in den Jahren, in denen ich noch ins Schauspiel ging, also bis zur Pandemie, dann haben die mich so völlig verloren, da hat sich der Eindruck bei mir verstärkt, dass dieses permanente Schreien plus Ironie dazu so ein Dauerbrenner geworden ist. Und Torsten, du gehst nicht nur in die Oper, sondern du öffnest deine Ohren auch für das Schreien auf Schauspielböen. Wie, erträgst du das oder siehst du das gar nicht so?
So, Herr Chef vom Theaterverlag, erklär mal.
Ach, danke für die Frage. Also, es ist einfach so, ich frag andersrum, wer ist schon mal in der Oper gewesen? Hand mal oben lassen, wer ist in der Oper gewesen ohne familiären Zwang? Das Oma gesagt hat, jetzt kommst du mal mit. Prima. Und wer bitte auch oben lassen, würde wieder in die Oper gehen.
Wir müssen noch fragen, wer ohne Wolfgang Zwang reingegangen ist.
Aber es sind sehr viele, die sich hier melden. Also, da würde ich sagen, das sind 50 Prozent fast gewesen jetzt.
Großen Respekt. Und wenn sie aus dem Rhein-Main-Gebiet kommen, bringe ich jetzt einfach mal zwei, drei kurze Empfehlungen, die es unbedingt lohnt. Und zwar vor zwei Jahren ist ein relativ selten gespieltes Stück von Tchaikovsky, Die Nacht vor Weihnachten, ein Stück des Jahres in der Operwelt geworden. Da sind also alle Kritiker im deutschsprachigen Raum, überall wo sie mal gewesen sind, und haben gesagt, das Stück ist so herausragend, wird auch relativ selten gespielt, vollkommen unverständlich, ist in der Inszenierung von Frankfurt unglaublich aufwendig, mit Schwebe-Elementen, wo es ganz wenige gibt, die wirklich dann wirklich dabei sind, um sicherzustellen, dass es da kein Unfall gibt, unten und unten und unten.
Die fliegen also durch die Bühne, ich habe das auch gesehen, die fliegen da auf der Bühne herum. Es gibt nur sechs, sonst nur von Helene Fischer. Aber hier funktioniert es auch.
Es gibt nur sechs Vorstellungen und ich glaube jetzt schon im November und Dezember, ich bin mir sicher, Anfang Oktober sind sie alle ausverkauft. Also beeilen, das lohnt sich wirklich. Und die dänische Nationaloper wird laufen, Masquerade, die einfach unglaublich unkompliziert, witzig, humorig ist. Die Musik ist sehr eingängig. Es gibt natürlich auch Opern, wo man drinsitzt und dann am Ende sagt, ja, 12-Ton-Technik und Schönberg hätte man machen können. Man hätte auch abends einfach nur Sogenglas reindrücken können. Nachher trinkt man die Flasche einfach nur, um die Erinnerung zu vergessen. Das passiert einfach auch manchmal. Und vielleicht, wenn man ein bisschen reinkommen möchte, wenn man sieht, dass der Komponist noch lebt, ist das schon mal ein eher schlechtes Thema. Zurück in die Frage. Nein.
Da muss Konzerti wieder sprechen.
Da würde ich dir schon wieder sprechen.
Das hatten wir erst gerade gehabt. Warum ist die Oper Frankfurt so gut? Weil die nämlich genau diese Sachen machen, weil die experimentell sind. Ich sage immer, flapsig natürlich auch nicht zum zitieren, es gibt diese Touristenopern und es gibt die Opern, die wirklich ein Programm machen, um das Programm zu werden. Um einfach Sachen auszuprobieren, um Stücke, die auch nicht so oft gespielt werden, teilweise weil unglaublich gut und meliodesch sind und die einfach Spaß machen, teilweise auch sicher für den normalen Hörer, auch für mich, ich bin wie gesagt kein ausgebildeter Theaterwissenschaftler oder Opernsänger oder ähnliches, auch ein bisschen ungewohnt sind, aber Frankfurt traut sich zu experimentieren, traut sich nach Stücken zu suchen, die nicht überall laufen und haben damit einen wahnsinnigen Erfolg. Andere, ganz kurz, ich höre gleich auf, andere Opern zum Beispiel sind so, möchte ich keine Namen sagen, aber wenn man nach Wien in ein großes Haus geht, dann kann man relativ sicher sein, dass da diese ganzen, ist ja mal Gassenhauer spielen, da kriegt man die Zauberflöte, da kriegt man AIDA, da kriegt man Tosca, alles mögliche und weiß einfach, dass die Bude damit voll ist. Was experimentell ist, was vielleicht ein bisschen schwieriger ist, findet man da nicht. In Dresden vermute ich in der Semperoper das Gleiche. Wie war die Frage eigentlich nochmal?
Es ging um dieses Schreien.
Ach ja.
Im Schauspiel und da hatte ich jetzt den Eindruck, da willst du ein wenig ausweichen.
Nee, gar nicht. Ja, das ist das Gute. Ich brauche nicht fragen, wer schon mal im Kino war, weil da haben wir alle Hände. Im Kino habe ich keine Möglichkeit, den Leuten, die auf der Leinwand sind, zu sagen, was ich von dem Stück halte. Ich habe noch nie erlebt, dass irgendjemand am Ende Buge rufen hat. Jetzt gerade Eröffnungen Bayreuth, Tristan und Sollich. Schon wieder, Opa. Es gab viele Buß relativ zu Recht auch. Im Schauspiel, um jetzt mal darauf zu kommen, habe ich die Möglichkeit, wenn mir ein Stück nicht gefällt, zu gehen. Und wenn ich gehe, habe ich auch schon gemacht, dann mache ich das natürlich nicht leise, sondern dann möchte ich ganz gern, dass alle um mich herum mitkriegen, dass ich dieses Stück, Entschuldigung, scheiße fand. Die Schauspieler können oftmals gar nichts dafür. Oftmals ist es ja die Sache des Regisseurs, der einfach ein bisschen sehr wüst im Kopf gewesen ist. Und dann, was auf die Bühne gebracht hat, was so anstrengend und so wirklich körperlich belastend sein kann, wo man sagt, tu ich mir das an oder gehe ich gleich zur Flasche? Und dann geht man relativ, man muss sich ja die Erinnerung wieder wechseln.
Und woher kommt jetzt dieser Trend, dass Regisseure gerne die Anweisung geben, viel schreien hilft? Also das muss ja ein Grund haben, dass man das, wenn man sich beispielsweise Aufnahmen anseht aus Schauspielinszenierungen der 60er, 70er Jahre, dass das in dieser Vehemenz nicht anzutreffen war.
Einfallslosigkeit.
Ah, sehr gute Erklärung.
Einfallslosigkeit, also einfach nur, wenn dir nichts einfällt.
Um Intensität zu erzeugen. Es gibt aber vielleicht auch noch ein wirklich ein ganz technisches Problem. Ist so ein bisschen meiner Erfahrung, ohne das jetzt richtig von dir sagen zu können. Also es gibt ja zwei Trends eigentlich. Es gibt einmal den Trend, dass wirklich wahnsinnig viel geschrien wird. Und dann gibt es den Trend, dass jeder Schauspieler einen Mikroport trägt. Und dann wird ganz viel geflüstert und so weiter. Ja, und dann sprechen die Leute nuscheln genauso, wie sie halt privat eben so sprechen würden, wenn du jetzt sozusagen in meiner Entfernung stehen würdest. Und ich glaube, das ist aber auch ein bisschen eine technische Frage. Ich habe früher, mein erstes Theater war so ein ausdeutsches Theater in Rostock, das Volkstheater. Und dort hattest du total krass diesen Unterschied zwischen diesen Leuten, die teilweise dort 30 Jahre engagiert waren, die aus einer ganz großen Theater-Tradition aus dem Osten kamen, die auf der Bühne sprechen konnten. Und du hattest das Gefühl, das ist überhaupt nicht einstrengend, was die dort tun. Du verstehst jedes Wort selbst, wenn du denkst, die flüstern. Und dann hattest du oft auch Leute, die gerade von der Schauspielschule kommen, auch von sehr renommierten Schauspielschulen, wo du denkst, die müssen sich unglaublich anstrengen, um überhaupt in die letzte Reihe zu kommen. Also das ist noch eine technische Sache, die dazukommt.
Ja, sehr wahrscheinlich. Nun, Constantin, du bist ja aus einer Musikerfamilie, da liegt es nahe, dass man auch in die Opernwelt hinein gerät. Wie ist das denn bei Leuten, die genau diesen Hintergrund nicht haben? Siehst du das als schwierig an? Nun haben wir jetzt hier sehr viele Leute, die sich gemeldet haben, dass sie schon in der Oper waren. Aber wie ist da dein Eindruck und was müsste eigentlich passieren, dass mehr junge Leute in die Oper gehen? Dann machen wir uns nichts vor. Es ist schon ein sehr ergrautes Publikum dort, auch wenn wir dann heute Abend ein bisschen mal den Gegenbeweis angetreten haben.
Ich kann das natürlich auch nicht so ganz gut beurteilen, weil ich zunehmend immer berufsblinder werde. Also wenn man wirklich jeden Tag von morgens bis nachts in der Oper verbringt, dann kann man das natürlich auch immer weniger nachvollziehen. Aber mich wundert natürlich schon immer wieder, oder mich wundern, der ich ja quasi in der Oper aufgewachsen bin, wirklich von Geburt an quasi auf der Bühne oder hinter der Bühne war, mich wundern dann schon so Vorurteile, die man gegen die Oper hat. Und auf diese Vorurteile, das würde mich gleich noch interessieren, Stefan, der du ja bis jetzt von Wolfgang irgendwie die Oper vermittelt bekommen hast, ja noch nicht so viel Berührung damit hattest. Hattest du auch mit diesen Vorurteilen zu kämpfen? Oder hattest du diese oder hattest du überhaupt gar keine Vorstellung, was Oper überhaupt ist?
Also ich habe manchmal Vorurteile oder sehe die von anderen. Ich kämpfe nie mit denen. Aber es ist tatsächlich so, dass ich sehr überrascht darüber war, wie gut gerade in der Oper, wo man es am wenigsten erwartet, die Generationenwechsel funktionieren. Also da ist einfach ein Generalmusikdirektor und der ist eigentlich noch gar nicht alt. Und er sagt sich aber trotzdem, ich gehe mal. Und dann kommt plötzlich so ein junges Wunderkind und man sieht den und liest so ein bisschen nach und fällt aus allen Wolken. Was das für Figuren sind, die da plötzlich am Dirigentenpult stehen und nicht nur das Orchester an diesem Abend leiten, sondern da einfach das ganze Haus schmeißen.
Ja, der Durchschnitt der Leute, die Oper machen, die sich dafür begeistern, dass sie ihr Leben wirklich, diese Operform widmen. Die sind ja jetzt im Schnitt, würde ich mal sagen, schon ziemlich jung. Es kommen ja unglaublich viele Nachwuchsleute und viel jünger als der Durchschnitt des Publikums.
Und das ist so interessant, weil im Fernsehen zum Beispiel, also um ein paar Medis abzuklopfen, im Fernsehen sieht man 50-, 60-Jährige, die für ein 70-Jähriges Programm machen. Wir haben extreme Nachwuchssorgen beim Sport. Ganz Deutschland jamert rum, wo ist der Nachwuchs, wo ist der Breitensport, nichts funktioniert, wie auch immer. Und dann gibt es diese Nische, die irgendwie von niemandem so richtig in der Breite gesehen wird. Und wenn man dann aber mal hingeht, stellt man fest, ups, auf der Bühne nur junge Leute, das Orchester irgendwie. Dann hat man gerade in Frankfurt mit der, ich weiß jetzt ihren Namen leider nicht, aber da gibt es Weihnachtskonzerte in der Musikhochschule und dann geht man dahin und sieht für 5 Euro den ganzen dreistündigen Händel und der ganze Kram. So und dann sieht man da einfach, wie jeder kleine Part einzeln gesungen wird, weil einfach 30 junge Menschen Schlange stehen, um da zu singen an diesem Abend. Also es ist unglaublich. Und das war eigentlich eins der größten Überraschungen überhaupt, dass man in die Oper geht und ich bin jetzt selber nicht sehr alt, aber auf der Bühne sind Schauspieler diesen jünger als ich. Also ich stelle gleich noch einen vor, wo es wirklich atemberaubend ist, solche Figuren dann zu begleiten. Und zwar nicht nur auf der Bühne, sondern darüber muss man gleich detailliert sprechen, auch abseits der Bühne. Also die haben ihre Instagram Kanäle und so weiter. Man blättert natürlich durchs Programmheft und sieht nichts davon, sondern nur noch mal in schwarz-weiß als Einleger. Wer singt denn heute mit so einer kleinen Briefmarke als Bild, wo man sich denkt, keine Ahnung, mal gucken, ob ich das erkenne auf der Bühne, wer da hinter der Maske steckt. Man geht in die Oper und ist plötzlich gar nicht in der Welt, in die man erwartet, weil doch so krasse Vorurteile irgendwie, und ich will gar nicht sagen Vorurteile, sondern so Vorstellungen von der Oper, wo ich mir denke, nee, das ist, warum hat das keine Breitenwirkung, frage ich mich dann immer. Weil nirgendwo in diesem Metier ist, liegen eigentlich, es ist die Arbeit besser vorbereitet für eine ordentliche Breitenwirkung.
Also was mich immer sehr überrascht hat ist, oder was mich, ich sag mal andersrum, was mich abstoßen würde, wenn ich mich mit Oper irgendwie beschäftigen würde und noch gar nicht darin irgendwie so Firmen wäre, ist eigentlich so eine Art von, dass das Klang am Anfang, auch als du die Oper vorgestellt hast oder als ihr gerade darüber gesprochen habt, ja man kann, muss so viele Inszenierungen sehen und du musst dieses Stück dann mal dort sehen und dort sehen. Also mein erstes Stück war ein Zwölfton. Butterfly, dort gut gefallen und dort hat sie mir nicht gut gefallen. Das ist immer so eine Art wie so Weinkennner über Weine sprechen. Und das ist etwas, was mich irgendwie immer total abgestoßen hat.
Aber du machst es ja auch. Also deine Gespräche, sei ehrlich, wir haben schon in Pausen zusammen gestanden. Es kamen noch Kollegen von dir, die dann sagen, ja also Nürnberg gerade schwierig oder Stuttgart interessant. Es werden ja genau diese Gespräche fortwährend geführt.
Vielleicht passiert mir das. Aber mit dir kann man wirklich sehr gut über solche Sachen sprechen.
Ich glaube, das ist ja für Leute, die sich jetzt intensiv damit beschäftigen wollen. Aber nicht jeder will sich intensiv damit beschäftigen. Nicht jeder, der einen Film eines Regisseurs sich anseht, liest dann gleich noch drei Biografien des Regisseurs. Das ist ja gar nicht notwendig. Ich glaube nur, dass wenn man so in dieses Opernding eintaucht, immer mehr, dann ist das glaube ich schon etwas, dass man ein bisschen mehr verfolgt, da und dort guckt, wo gibt es etwas Interessantes zu erleben und wo nicht. Und das muss nicht dünkelhaft sein.
Und ich glaube, die Oper ist ein bisschen mit Vorurteilen behaftet. Und zwar, sie wäre elitär. Es gab gerade in Hamburg eine Umfrage dazu. Was verbinden Sie mit der Oper? Sie ist elitär. Warum ist sie elitär? Die Eintrittspreise sind so teuer. Wissen Sie, was ein Eintrittspreis, was eine Karte kostet? Nein, weiß ich nicht. Werden Sie überrascht sein, dass ein Unterschied zwischen Oper und zum Beispiel Kino gar nicht mal so groß ist? In Darmstadt kostet die preiswerteste Karte für eine Opernaufführung, das ist nun die teuerste produktion des Mehrspartenhauses, 11 Euro. In Frankfurt kostet sie 16 Euro. Viele Häuser haben inzwischen die Situation, dass sie Theatertage machen oder Operntage, wo alle Karten 8, 9, 10 Euro kosten, wo man also reingehen kann.
Es haben sich ja gerade auch viele gemeldet, die jetzt unter 30 sind. Also bei uns zum Beispiel kriegt man da Karten für 15 Euro, wenn man so eine Juniorkarte dazu kauft. Und dann eben nicht nur die niedrigste Kategorie sind, eben auch gute Plätze.
Und die nächste Frage ist immer, natürlich sieht man gerade, wenn in Bayreuth die A-,
B-
und C-Promis über die roten Teppich laufen, alle als Pinguin verkleidet und so was, im Smoking, im was auch immer. Zur normalen Opernaufführung gehe ich genauso, wie ich gerade bin, in Jeans und Turnschuhen. Und das ist absolut okay. Und da muss man sich irgendwie rausputzen. Ich glaube, jeder, auch dem Opernhaus, jedem Opernhaus, ist jeder einfach nur willkommen, der Interesse an den Inhalten hat. Und wenn da jemand nicht so gekleidet ist, wie in dem 19. Jahrhundert, ist es vollkommen egal.
Aber das war eben auch was total Ungewöhnliches für mich. Also, früher bin ich noch ganz anders rumgelaufen. Ich meine, jetzt habe ich ja auch einen Anzug an oder zumindest einen Sacko. Aber früher habe ich tagsüber geprobt zum Beispiel oder habe geschrieben und so weiter und hatte dann irgendwie ein T-Shirt an. Und ich hatte irgendwie auf so einem Second Hand Laden so einen Lammfellmantel gefunden, den ich immer getragen habe. Dann bin ich einfach von der Probe so in die Oper gegangen. Und ein paar Leute haben mich vielleicht komisch angeguckt. Aber für mich, ich habe da überhaupt nicht dran gedacht, dass man sich irgendwie anzieht für die Oper. Auf der anderen Seite ist es ja auch was relativ Außergewöhnliches heutzutage, dass man Anlass hat, sich auch schick anzuziehen oder sowas. Das hat natürlich auch was, dieses Rummel.
Der Trick bei mir ist, ich sehe immer so aus, als würde ich gleich in der Oper gehen. Das geht auch. Aber, Sterran, du hast sehr interessante Clips, um ein bisschen den Blick hinter die Kulissen zu werfen, um uns mal ein bisschen zu zeigen. Wir sind ja schon in der Zeit etwas fortgeschritten, wie sich jetzt diese Klassikwelt jenseits der Opernbühne auch inszeniert, nämlich zum Beispiel bei Instagram.
Genau, also wir haben hier Nikolas Brownlee. Du, Constantin, kannst du das bestimmt genauer sagen, wer das ist. Aber ich habe ihn jetzt ein paar Mal gesehen, zum Beispiel als Torero bei Carmen. Und man sieht sofort, hier ist ein Weltstar auf der Bühne. Er ist jünger als alle, die im Publikum sitzen. Also ich weiß nicht genau, wie alt er ist, aber irgendwas in den hohen 80er-Jahrgängen, keine Ahnung. Und er hat einen Instagram-Kanal. Und da steckt genau all das drin, was ich mir eigentlich aus dem Programmheft wünsche. Klar, Bewegtbild ist schwierig, aber man kann ihn hier zum Beispiel kurz vor der Aufführung noch mal sehen.
In Bademantel.
Ja, ich mach uns das mal ein bisschen lauter auf.
Im Bademantel in der Garderobe wird es für uns eingesungen.
In seiner Garderobe, okay, das ist noch relativ berufsnah. Aber er hängt zum Beispiel, hinten rechts hab ich Ian Dinksterbombs erkannt, auch aus dem Ensemble Frankfurt. Ihn hab ich zuerst als Odysse in Ulisse gesehen. Also meine erste Oper war Zwölftonmusik und es hat mich nicht verschreckt. Also man kann sich durchaus einfach darauf einlassen, egal was gespielt wird. Und dann sitzt man hier in Frankfurt, je nachdem, wo das offene Fenster ist, kann man das dann wahrscheinlich auch live hören. Ist das Arbeitszeit oder machen die das so privat, was ist das? Das ist jetzt privat, aber wird das als Pauschalhonora abgerechnet?
Die arbeiten schon wirklich genug.
Und hier haben wir einen ganz seltenen Einblick, denn das ist wirklich schade. Ich habe natürlich auch ein bisschen gesucht. Bühnrealität gibt es bei Instagram kaum. Hinterbühnen gibt es, Privatreume gibt es, Bühne selten. Wir hören ihn hier. Da hinten in der Ecke steht Nicholas Brown-Liem. So, ich hab meine Karte für jeder schon. Ich bin gespannt und jetzt ist es interessant, denn das ist natürlich jetzt ein Stück, wo ich sagen würde, ja, das ist halt irgendwie so typisch Oper. Man kann da ruhig Christopher Nolan mäßig reingehen und sagen, es reicht, das zu fühlen. Man muss hier nichts verstehen. Oben läuft der Text. Wenn es nicht auf Deutsch ist und selbst wenn es auf Deutsch ist, versteht man wahrscheinlich sowieso nichts, sondern die Stimme ist ein Instrument. Bei Instagram, anders als im Programmheft, kann man dann aber zu dem kleinen Stück, was wir gerade gesehen haben, diesen Text finden. Brownleesh selbst schreibt darüber, wie er dieses Stück gerade gesungen hat. Und es schreibt dann unten drunter, ja vielleicht kann ich das mal öfter machen, hat Spaß gemacht darüber zu schreiben. Also das sind eher Insights sozusagen, wie man wahrscheinlich als Arbeitgeber, also als Opa nicht aus ihm rauskitzeln könnte, aber er macht das halt auf Instagram so.
Also er schreibt.
Er schreibt es ja natürlich vor allem erstmal für mich. So, keine Ahnung, ich fühle mich da angesprochen, ich lese mir das dann einmal durch.
Du hast es gleich nachgemacht dann.
Genau, ich verstehe nichts, Kopfstimme, Bauchstimme, was auch immer, er will halt... So, jetzt hat er ja drüber geschrieben, es muss ja nicht immer Wagner sein. Und jetzt ist ja die Frage, du warst jetzt in Bayreuth, da wird immer Wagner gespielt, Wagner, Wagner, Wagner, überall Wagner, wenn in Frankfurt Wagner gespielt ist, ist gleich der Wagner-Verein da und quatscht einen so von der Seite an. Und jetzt sagt er Brownlee aber, den ich natürlich auch als Hans Sachs zuerst gesehen habe, also auch Wagner, Wagner, Wagner, der Jüngste, der diese Rolle spielte wahrscheinlich. Er steht jetzt hier in Wuppertal vor der Oper und dieser Clip ist ganz interessant, weil wir hatten jetzt über diese Vorurteile gesprochen, er redet jetzt mal über Wagner. Und wir denken uns so, das ist aber sehr hemmsärmlich und salopp, aber er ist eben der Wagner-Sänger. Und wenn selbst er so darüber reden kann, warum dann nicht wir alle eigentlich auch?
Listen, maybe I'm just in a birthday place and maybe I'm overwhelmed, but that ending gets me. And everybody's like Wagner's Long. F you, Wagner's Long. The stakes are so high, it's death. You're gonna come on stage and sing Pári de Jocára. No, no. Verdi has a place, of course, but golly. The resolution, I mean, what are you even doing? Wagner's Long. The stakes are so high, it's death. Sit in your stupid chair and if you get bored, think about something for a minute and then come back in. God, it's the best music in the whole wide world. We're so lucky to be able to do it. Opera's so alive in Europe and I'm so grateful for it. It's the best thing in the world. We're doing Ligeti right now in Frankfurt, then we're doing Giancarlo, then we're doing Aida, and then there's a Tristan and Wuppertal. It's like so incredible. The thing we all love so much is so alive here.
Also, jeder darf, egal wie, über die Oper reden. Und wenn er so reden darf, ist das einfach absolut legitim. Man geht in so ein Stück und findet das irgendwie cool. Und dann sagt man halt, das war cool.
So, was kann man ja in der Opernwelt, es noch mal anders sich zu Gemüte führen oder in den Programmhälften?
Oder in einem Programmheft. Also, das Programmheft...
Also, ich glaube, das Problem ist ja nicht, dass nicht die Angebote gemacht werden, auch anders über Oper zu reden. Im Gegenteil, ich würde sogar sagen, dass viele Leute gerade auch in die Oper gehen, weil da mal nicht ein solches Sprechen vorherrscht, wie wir das kennen, wenn Leute vom Taylor Swift-Konzert oder so erzählen, um jetzt hier eine kleine Provokation zu setzen. Es ist also durchaus ja so, dass man darüber nachdenken kann, ob es nicht auch ein anderes Sprechen manchmal verlangt. Also was nicht jetzt bedeutet, erst wer die Partitur gefressen hat, kann darüber sprechen. Ich kann auch keine Partituren lesen. Aber mir scheint doch, dass zumindest das Sinnangebot, das die Oper macht, ein vielfältigeres ist, als dass das Popkonzert einem bringen kann.
Ja, Torsten, ist die Opernwelt ein Angebot in die Opernwelt? Rein sozialisiert zu werden. Und zwar nicht im Sinne von, ich habe nachgelesen, ich weiß jetzt Bescheid und kann sozusagen wiedergeben, was ich gelesen habe, sondern um auch leichter abgeholt zu werden, sozusagen als kleiner Appetizer oder so. Also gar nicht die große Werkbesprechung, sondern wir besprechen das auch gleich am Vötor zum Buch. Es gibt die Literatur und das literarische Leben. Ist die Opernwelt zum Beispiel auch ein Magazin für Opernleben, Publikumsein, wie auch immer?
Ich freue mich über jeden, der die Opernwelt liest. Gar keine Frage.
Soll ich was erst mal antworten? Also ich glaube, die Opernwelt setzt sich schon wirklich sehr komplex mit Oper auseinander. Das ist jetzt doch schon auch für Leute, für ein paar Fachbepluckungen und für Leute, die wirklich begeistert sind von Oper und auch dort tiefer einsteigen möchten. Man kann natürlich auch wirklich sich da reinlesen und auch mal überlegen, wie kann man sich eigentlich mit Oper beschäftigen. Das ist aber, das spricht die Sache an und mit der ich mich jetzt auch in Wiesbaden, wo ich ja Chefdramaturg war, wo meine Aufgabe war, irgendwie auch Oper zu vermitteln und Zugänge für Oper zu schaffen, auf verschiedene Arten, unter anderem Programmhefte habe ich geschrieben, aber auch so Formate, dass Wolfgang und ich zum Beispiel bei so Operntalks diskutiert haben vor Publikum. Es gibt eigentlich so zwei Seiten. Auf der einen Seite ist Oper unglaublich komplex. Das ist so eine Sache, je mehr man da reinsteigt, desto komplexer wird es. Also du fängst an, dich mit einem Libretto zu beschäftigen oder mit einem Operntext und dann tauchen ganz viele Fragen auf. Dann kann man darüber Bücher lesen, Dissertationen schreiben und so weiter. Das fächert sich immer mehr auf. Aber gleichzeitig muss man das alles nicht vorher wissen, um in eine Oper zu gehen. Das ist ja das Erstaunliche, dass man in Opernaufführungen gehen kann und sofort wirklich gepackt werden kann damit, ohne wirklich zu wissen, was da eigentlich vorgeht. Dann wird man vielleicht so fasziniert davon, dass man sich tiefer damit beschäftigt. Man darf auch nicht den Fehler machen, dass man sagt, Oper ist total einfach. Ich hatte mal eine Kollegin, die sagte immer, Oper ist total normal, genauso wie wir morgens Zähne putzen und so weiter, gehen wir abends in die Oper. Ich dachte immer, nein, das stimmt doch gar nicht. Oper ist unglaublich komplex, überwältigend. Man kann auch ganz komplex, auch politisch übrigens, darüber diskutieren. Also wir zum Beispiel haben ja wirklich über ein Stück zum Beispiel gesprochen, wir haben über den Ring gesprochen, wir haben aber auch über Figaro beispielsweise gesprochen und haben da Marx gestreift, wo sind wir noch an allen möglichen Ecken hingelangt, Bakunin und so weiter, alles von Wagner ausgehend und wirklich sehr komplexe politische Theorie daran entwickelt. Und diese Seite hat Oper natürlich auch, man kann sich auf ganz viele verschiedene Arten damit beschäftigen.
Und das ist gerade in Frankfurt ganz wunderbar, dass selbst wenn man es zeitlich nicht geschafft hat, sich mit einem Stück vorab zu beschäftigen. Also bei mir ist es so, wenn mein Chefredakteur der Opernwelt, Jürgen Otten, wenn der in ein Stück geht, was er noch nicht gesehen hat, es werden immer irgendwelche Sachen wieder ausgegraben, Uhr aufgeführt, wie auch immer, dann beschäftigt er sich einen Tag mit den Noten, mit den Biografien derjenigen, die alle daran beteiligt sind, mit den Sängerinnen und Sängern, mit der Zeit, in der er spielt, unter und unter. Ich nehme mir das natürlich auch vor, schaffe es, wenn überhaupt, auf dem Weg zur Oper, den Wikipedia-Artikel drüber zu lesen. Und ärgere mich daran, dass ich eigentlich manchmal ein bisschen überrascht war, bzw. wenn das mit den Übertiteln, oder Bayreuth hat leider Gottes gar keine Übertitel, weil es wirklich jetzt gerade auch mit einer der Hauptkritikpunkte gewesen ist in Tristan und Insolte bei der Eröffnung, dass man also, da sinkt er 40 Minuten vor sich hin und man weiß eigentlich gar nicht, wo man gerade ist, weil man es auch leider Gottes akustisch so zumindest den Gesang nicht verstanden hat. Und da ist Frankfurt ganz wunderbar. Es lohnt sich einfach diese halbe Stunde vorher im Haus zu sein, weil die Qualität der Operneinführungen wirklich phänomenal ist. Also ich habe angeregt mal, dass wir in der Opernwelt einen Beitrag machen, einfach nur, dass ich mit Operneinführungen beschäftige. Da hat man Menschen, die stockend den Wikipedia-Artikel vorlesen und alle eigenen Namen der handelnden Personen gerne auch nochmal falsch aussprechen. Und dann hat man aber auch Menschen, der war damals 19, Robin Pallard, der hat ohne ein Blatt Papier zu haben, einfach weil er ein Freak, das muss man wirklich sagen, 19-Jähriger und richtig Opern begeistert ist, einfach über ein Stück geschwärmt und dann, jetzt muss ich langsam aufhören, weil es geht gleich los. Und das ist nicht nur, da passiert es auch generell, meistens machen sie Dramatogen, die in dieses Stück einführen. Und das ist so, dass man eigentlich die Vorabbeschäftigung mit erfahren, sondern da einfach genau dieses Handwerkzeug kommt, um zu wissen, in welcher Zeit man gerade ist, welche Besonderheiten gerade die Frankfurter Oper damit gemacht hat und sie einfach richtig geobert wird.
Ja, die Opern-Einführung sind eine gute Schlüssel. Allerdings muss man dann sein Ticket schon gekauft haben und schon anwesend sein. Der Zugang zur Oper ist sozusagen Voraussetzung dafür. Wir haben gerade im Bockenheimer Depot wirklich hervorragende Einführungen gesehen, die dann aus dem Stegreif eine Viertelstunde lang uns jede Form der Melodieentwicklung vorwärts, rückwärts spiegeln, was auch immer noch mal erklärt hat. Trotzdem dieser Zugang zur Oper. Also die Opernwelt richtet sich an Menschen, die schon Opernerfahrung haben. Ich habe da auch sozusagen Inszenierungsvergleiche zum selben Werke gelesen. Das ist natürlich super interessant, wenn man, so wie ich, den Frankfurter Tannhäuser kennt. Und dann von jemandem liest, der noch mal die andere, vielleicht sogar von demselben Team, das die Inszenierung macht, aber eben eine andere und woanders usw. Also da kann man sich dann da reinnörden, das Programmheft. Ja, das liegt nun auch nicht kostenlos vor der Oper, sondern man kommt rein und muss erstmal fünf Euro zahlen, damit man da einen Zugang hat.
Also ihr merkt, Stefan macht jetzt so einen ganz langen Anlauf, um jetzt am Ende zu sagen, naja, mit der Vertiefung und dem ganzen Gut und Schön, aber.
Aber, also die Oper hat ja einen Zugang, der sehr gut funktioniert, das ist nämlich einfach die Sozialisation. Oper für Kinder, am Wochenende, Vormittags, wie auch immer. Man begrüßt das junge Publikum. Und, das fand ich sehr interessant dieses Jahr, wir hatten eine Europameisterschaft. Frankfurt hat sich gesagt, komm, wir bauen den größten Fernseher Deutschlands. Der stand also hier auf dem Main und daneben eine große Bühne. Das Museums- und Opernorchester hat einen Ausflug gemacht. Wir hören jetzt Ausschnitte davon, die die Oper selbst auf Instagram publiziert hat. Wir hören ungefähr anderthalb Minuten zu. Ihr zählt mit, wie viele verschiedene Werke ihr erkennt. Und überlegt dann bei jedem, kenn ich das eigentlich und gefällt es mir. Und dann zieht jeder für sich im Kopf mal Bilanz, wie viele Stücke habe ich da gerade gehört, wie viel davon kannte ich schon und wie viel gefiel mir.
Da werden jetzt einige Lust auf Pizza bekommen haben, denke ich.
Ja, ich möchte einen Verdacht äußern. In den Momenten, in denen die Oper weiß, wir haben ja eine einmalige Chance, Laufpublikum. Es ist dafür gesorgt, wir brauchen nur noch Programm. Bedient man sich bei einer Quelle und sagt, was macht eigentlich dieser Herr da immer?
Und da blendet Stefan natürlich sein großes Idol, André Rieu, ein.
Da war auch ein bisschen Unbekanteres noch dabei, muss ich jetzt in Anführungszeichen Ehrenrettung sagen.
Ja, ich glaube, den Brahms hätte er nicht gespielt.
Man hat auf der Bühne vielleicht noch ein paar Sachen untergekriegt, aber für Instagram hat man dann genau die Highlights sich rausgesucht. Allerdings, das ist ja nur Pointhe, erster Teil. Klar, André Rieu hat halt den Schlüssel zum Erfolg gefunden. Ich bin auch nur angefixt über die, sag ich mal im Groben jetzt, klassische Musik, weil ich halt, wenn André Rieu hier in der Festhalle spielt, in die Festhalle gefahren bin und erst dann Jahre später in die Oper. Aber das ist Sebastian Weigle, also unser Generalmusikdirektor vor Thomas Guggeis, dem neuen jungen Wunderkind, das jetzt die Geschäfte führt. Und wir hören ihn mal über Musik, die Oper und so weiter reden. Und ich will sagen, André Rieu macht auch nichts anderes.
Wünsche für die Oper Frankfurt immer neugierig bleiben, immer offen bleiben, immer Musik machen. Weil Musik ist eine internationale, grenzenlose Sprache. Und die alle Grenzen, wenn sie da sind, überwinden können und sich in die Herzen der Menschen hereinbohren. Unsere Truppe ist ja hier so international geworden. Ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, wir haben, glaube ich, im Orchester 27 Nationen. Und das werden wahrscheinlich auch immer mehr. Und das ist so vielfältig, ja. Und jeder bringt da so von seinem Hintergrund Erfahrungen mit und so weiter, die sich dann in den Klang irgendwie mit einmischen, um dann eins zu werden.
Ja, Joy Fleming sang ja schon, ein Lied kann eine Brücke sein.
Ja, in die Herzen bohren, Grenzen überwinden.
Ja, ich bin jetzt ganz fies und sage, Musiker sind oft sehr gute Musiker, aber nicht die idealen Leute, um darüber zu sprechen. Sie haben sich auch deswegen für eine Musikerkarriere entschieden. Also so wenig, wie ich jetzt Geige spielen kann, kann vielleicht der, der gut Geige spielen kann, über das sprechen, was er da so eigentlich macht. Und ja, das sind natürlich sehr viele Plattitüden, die auch alle irgendwo stimmen und die auch aus dem Munde von André Rieu kommen können oder ich muss auch gerade denken, als russische Oligarchen, es schafften, dass Albano und Romina Power, dieses Italo-Pop-Schlager-Duo wieder zusammen kamen, sagte Romina, wir sind zusammengekommen, denn ohne Musik kann niemand leben. Möglicherweise gab es noch andere Beweggründe, aber gut. Das ist so und deswegen ist ja meine Haltung auch immer, gar nicht so viel die Künstler reden lassen. Die Künstler machen Kunst, wir reden über die Kunst, aber die Künstler reden eher nicht über die Kunst.
Das ist also Wolfgangs Appell, ihr könnt euch dem anschließen. Oper kann man schon sagen, muss man dann auch mal erleben. Man kann nicht nur über die Oper reden, wenn man aber Oper erlebt hat, muss man nicht unbedingt über sie reden. Die Oper steht so im Kern des Ganzen. Am Ende können wir natürlich auch nur den Appetizer machen. Ich habe mir jetzt schon zehn Karten für die neue Spielzeit geholt. Es werden 25 Stück oder so gespielt. Mein Plan ist natürlich schon, jetzt mal alles zu sehen. Die Oper Frankfurt macht natürlich immer viel. Das sind ja elf.
Es gibt nicht mehr viele Opernhäuser, die so viel spielen und vor allem auch so viel neu produzieren wie wir. Es gibt viele Opernhäuser, die spielen dann tatsächlich wirklich 70 Jahre alte Inszenierungen oder sowas. Bei uns sind das ja wirklich alles Inszenierungen, die dort entstanden sind, eigentlich in Frankfurt. Wenn man wirklich alles sehen möchte, dann Respekt, Stefan.
Warum nicht?
Lass mich noch eine Abschlussfrage stellen an beide. Gab es für euch ein Erweckungserlebnis in der Oper? Gab es irgendeinen Moment, bei dem euch so klar war, das ist etwas, was ich weiter verfolgen werde? Ich werde nicht mehr von der Oper ablassen.
Also es sind zwei Sachen. Das eine ist Nabokow, der Gefangenenkor, der so phänomenal ist. Ich kriege jetzt schon wieder Gänsehaut. Einfach ist zigmal auf YouTube, wenn ihr heute nach Hause geht. Hört es euch einfach mal an. Und wer da irgendwie keine Gefühle dabei hat, der hat überhaupt gar keine, nicht? Und das andere ist Tchaikowski, Eugen Olegien. Da gibt es ein Stück, das heißt Polonesien, ganz langsam, ganz leise. Dann kommt es mit einer Wucht raus. Und auch das ist wieder so ein Gänsehautmoment, kann man eigentlich sagen. Also ist beides noch nicht von andere Réjeux gespielt worden. Das ist wichtig. Und danach hat man einfach so viele Emotionen. Damit fühlt man sich so gut und so mitten im Leben, dass man einfach sagt, da will ich mehr davon.
Constantin.
Ja, bei mir haben diese Momente schon zu früh eingesetzt, dass ich das gar nicht mehr auf diesen einen Moment bringen kann. Aber ich hatte doch immer wieder Momente, wo ich zum ersten Mal vielleicht etwas gesehen habe oder wo ich etwas in einer Form gesehen habe, wo ich dachte, das ist unwiederholbar. Also manchmal habe ich dann auch Inszenierungen mehrmals gesehen oder Ausführungen. Ich dachte, nein, ich habe das Gefühl, das war nur ein einziges Mal. Und dort war es so unglaublich stark, dass man dann das Gefühl hatte, das verändert eigentlich das Leben. Also wenn ich daran denke, an den Schluss von Wagner, Tristan und Isolde, wo sich dann am Ende eigentlich alles so ins Nichts öffnet und nachdem man diese Oper sozusagen gemeinsam mit tausend anderen Menschen in Anführungszeichen durchlitten hat und dann wird man entlassen irgendwie in diese Weite des Weltalls, das kann schon wirklich, hat man das Gefühl, das verändert das Leben. Und da gibt es schon einige Momente, wie Opern von Richard Strauss haben, also der Rosenkavalier zum Beispiel, da gibt es Momente von unglaublicher Tiefe und wo man sozusagen Strauss nimmt dann die Oberfläche und guckt da drunter und man sieht unter die Oberfläche von so vielen Menschen, mit denen man täglich begegnet, ist so unglaublich viel Tiefe und das versteht man dadurch die Musik. Aber ich lasse mich immer wieder überraschen und es sind auch Sachen, Opern, die ich vielleicht schon mal gesehen habe oder auch häufiger gesehen habe, wo ich dachte, mit denen kann ich so wenig anfangen. Das berührt mich irgendwie überhaupt nicht und dann gibt es wieder, dann sehe ich wieder doch mal irgendetwas. Marta ist so ein Beispiel, wo ich mit dich lange nicht anfangen konnte. So manche Operette, aber dann manchmal sieht man das wieder und denkt, ah, da ist doch viel mehr drin und plötzlich berührt es einen. Insofern glücklicherweise erlebe ich immer wieder solche Momente.
Ja, das ist ein sehr schönes Schlusswort und das ist das Tolle. Deshalb rennen wir immer wieder hin, um diese Momente zu erleben, nicht um uns nur zu erinnern an diese Momente. Wir haben jetzt gerade eine Kulturindustrie aus Hollywood, die nur noch Erinnerungen wachruft, wie schön der Film von 1987 war. Aber eigentlich entsteht im Moment nichts mehr Neues bei der Oper. Interessanterweise erneuert sich das Werk, vielleicht weil man eine gewisse starre Form hat, eine Ritualisierung hat und plötzlich ist dann das Neue da, wo man es nicht vermutet hat. Du hast den Rosenkavalier erlebt, als ich dann kürzlich den in Mainz einmal widersah und an einer Stelle weinte, die mir vorher nie aufgefallen war. Dann denkt man, wie oft bin ich an Sachen schon vorbei gegangen, muss sie nochmal hören, um das dann wirken zu lassen.
Ein Argument für die Oper übrigens noch für diesen Saal ist vielleicht, dass wenn man viel in der Oper unterwegs ist, relativ häufig Wolfgang trifft.
Jetzt wollen wir uns, vielen Dank, jetzt wollen wir uns ein bisschen mit Literatur auseinandersetzen und da hatte Stefan die Idee, wir müssen auch hier so ein Stimmungsbild einfangen, wenn knapp 800 Leute da sind, dann könnte man ja mal fragen, wie es denn mit der Lektüre in diesem Jahr so aussieht und wir wollen es jetzt auf Literatur, also das Nicht-Sachbuch, sagen wir mal, beschränken, denn Sachbücher, da sind wir ja natürlich durch den Salon und so alle sehr im Bilde, aber mit der Literatur als solcher, sei es jetzt Science-Fiction, Liebesroman oder so, ist das ja so eine Sache.
Wollen wir durchzählen?
Wer hat denn was gelesen bzw. konkreter gefragt?
Wir können ja von unten anfangen. Also ich habe meinen letzten Roman vor über zehn Jahren gelesen, also sagen wir mal den Neuen, ich lese immer mal wieder Krabatt, aber ansonsten, wer hat denn in den letzten zehn Jahren mehr Romane gelesen als ich? Also mehr als null. Okay, okay, gut.
Das ist beruhigend, also Stefan hier deutlich überstimmt.
Wer kommt denn auf ein Roman pro Jahr mindestens? Ein Roman pro Halbjahr?
Da sind auch noch ganz, ganz viele.
Ein Roman pro Quartal, pro Monat?
Und dann sind wir jetzt vielleicht noch bei vier, fünf Prozent. Ja, genau. Und das ist schon viel, denn es ist ja so, dass ganz viele Leute nie zu einem Buch greifen. Im Übrigen lesen mehr Frauen als Männer, also regelmäßig zu Büchern greifen. Ich glaube, wenn ich die Zahlen richtig in meinem Kopf habe, etwa 36 Prozent der Frauen. Bei den Männern sind es um die 20 Prozent. Und ja, es gibt viele Booktalk-Trends und all das, aber man kann doch sagen, dass die Literatur es schwer hat. Interessanterweise aber nicht nur unter uns Irrtischen, sondern auch unter jenen, die schon an die Ewigkeit denken, nämlich an die Priester. In diesem Monat hat Papst Franziskus ein Schreiben veröffentlicht. Das sollte eigentlich erst nur gedacht sein für die Priesteramtskandidaten. Nämlich eine Aufforderung, dass sie sich mit Literatur und Poesie auseinandersetzen sollen. Und dann, als er es schrieb, dachte aber Franziskus, so leitet er dann diese Schreiben ein, daran, dass das doch eigentlich etwas sei, das an alle gesandt werden sollte. Und so ist das also veröffentlicht worden. Franziskus schreibt über die Literatur. Nun ist es so, dass er nur einen Text veröffentlicht hat. Er hat das nicht eingelesen. Deswegen habe ich einige Passagen eingelesen. Ihr müsst euch jetzt also vorstellen, dass ich der Papst bin. Aber das ist ja im Grunde auch nicht so schwer.
Die Alternative, Wolfgang hätte hier live gelesen, aber dann hätten wir das Ticket teurer machen müssen, weil das dann Special Interest ist.
Ach so, ja.
Jetzt gehen wir nur Wolfgang aus der Konserve.
Also wir hören mal rein, was der Papst sagt. Mit wenigen Ausnahmen wird in der Priesterausbildung die Beschäftigung mit der Literatur als etwas Unwesentliches betrachtet. Diesbezüglich möchte ich sagen, dass dieser Ansatz nicht gut ist. Er ist die Ursache für eine ernsthafte intellektuelle und spirituelle Verarmung der künftigen Priester, die so eines privilegierten Zugangs zum Herzen der menschlichen Kultur und insbesondere zum Herzen des Menschen durch die Literatur beraubt werden. Mit diesem Beitrag möchte ich einen radikalen Kurswechsel hinsichtlich der großen Aufmerksamkeit anregen. Und diese Aufmerksamkeit lenkt er aber dann nicht nur auf die Priesterausbildung, also die Literatur muss in den Mittelpunkt gerückt werden, sondern das gilt auch für alle Menschen. Er selbst hat auch als Lehrer eine Zeit lang unterrichtet, an einem Jesuiten-Kolleg, hat dort auch mit ihnen gelesen, nicht nur Kanon, sondern die dortigen Schüler wollten dann auch Aktuelles lesen. Darauf hat er sich immer eingelassen. Er ist sowieso dafür, dass man nicht etwas lesen sollte, nur um danach darüber gelehrt sprechen zu können, sondern es muss um diese Herzensbildung gehen. Und wir hören mal, wie er sich das eigentlich vorstellt, wann benötigt man das Buch. Und wir haben ja diese, wie Jonathan Haidt das nennt, smartphone-basierte Kindheit. Und ich würde sagen, wir alle haben ein ziemlich smartphone-basiertes Leben. Und jetzt malt sich Franziskus aus, wie die Literatur wieder zur Geltung kommt, beziehungsweise wann wir sie benötigen. Oft wird in der Langeweile des Urlaubs, in der Hitze und Einsamkeit verlassener Stadtviertel ein gutes Buch zu einer Oase, die uns von anderen Entscheidungen, die uns nicht guttun, abhält. Dann gibt es die Momente der Müdigkeit, des Ärgers, der Enttäuschung, des Scheiterns. Und wenn es uns nicht einmal im Gebet gelingt, zur Ruhe zu kommen, dann hilft uns ein gutes Buch zumindest, den Sturm zu überstehen, bis wir ein wenig mehr Gelassenheit finden können. Und vielleicht eröffnet uns die Lektüre neue innere Räume, die uns helfen, uns nicht in jenen wenigen zwanghaften Ideen zu verschließen, die uns unerbittlich gefangen halten. Vor der Allgegenwart von Medien, sozialen Netzwerken, Mobiltelefonen und anderen Geräten war dies eine häufige Erfahrung. Und diejenigen, die sie gemacht haben, wissen, wovon ich spreche. So unterscheidet er auch eigentlich wie Jonathan Haidt in diesem Buch Generation der Angst zwischen denen, die nur das Smartphone-basierte Leben kennen und denjenigen, die noch das andere Leben kennengelernt haben. Also ich habe ja noch das andere Leben kennengelernt, beziehungsweise lebe ja noch ohne Smartphone, aber bin natürlich sonst im Internet hin und wieder vertreten, wie alle wissen. Nun ist es ja interessant, dass er so eine Ruhemarke da setzt mit dem Buch. Also diese Art der Vertiefung, die da stattfindet. Und das bedeutet natürlich auch, dass man sich von den anderen Medien löst. Und die Frage ist ja auch, warum setzt er so besonders auf die Literatur? Hätte ja auch was über die Oper sagen können. Er meint folgendes. Im Gegensatz zu den audiovisuellen Medien, bei denen das produkt vollständiger ist und der Spielraum und die Zeit, die Erzählung zu bereichern oder zu interpretieren, in der Regel geringer sind, ist der Leser beim Lesen eines Buches viel aktiver. Er schreibt das Werk in gewisser Weise um, erweitert es mit seiner Vorstellungskraft, erschafft eine Welt, nutzt seine Fähigkeiten, sein Gedächtnis, seine Träume, seine eigene Geschichte voller Dramatik und Symbolik. Und so entsteht ein Werk, das sich von dem unterscheidet, das der Autor zu schreiben beabsichtigte. Bei der Lektüre wird der Leser durch das, was er vom Autor erhält, bereichert, was ihm aber gleichzeitig erlaubt, sich im Reichtum seiner eigenen Person zu entfalten, so dass jedes neue Werk, das er liest, sein persönliches Universum erneuert und erweitert. Da sind wir doch eigentlich in einem Diskurs, der in den 60er-, 70er-Jahren aufkommt, nicht nur in der Literaturwissenschaft, aber da beginnt es eigentlich, wo man sagt, wir müssen auf die rezeptionsästhetischen Aspekte stärker eingehen. Jeder liest sein Buch. Es ist nicht einfach nur der Autor, der predigt, sondern das Buch entsteht beim Leser. Eigentlich will ja Roland Barth den Autor töten, um den Leser zu emanzipieren. Und hier das ist, was Franziskus sagt, im Prinzip in dieser Tradition und eine sehr moderne Sichtweise von Literatur. Erstaunlich, oder?
Schreiben und Lesen ist ja sowieso immer wieder crazy, weil man sitzt so alleine da und schreibt so vor sich hin. Da sitzt ja jetzt kein Publikum oder so. Man weiß gar nicht, wer das liest. Und ich habe in der KS auch schon gefragt, wenn wir jetzt lesen und der Autor ist schon tot, was ist das eigentlich für Kommunikation? Also es ist ja auch eigentlich total skurril, wenn man darüber nachdenkt. Beim Film klappt es noch so ein bisschen, aber wenn wir jetzt irgendwie auf Instagram eine Story anschauen, von jemandem, von dem wir wissen, der ist gerade gestorben, ist irgendwie so schräg. Also der Autor ist schon so weit ausgeblendet und man ist so mit dem Text alleine, während man ihn liest. Das ist schon verrückt. Das gibt es, glaube ich. Also ich wüsste jetzt nicht, in welchem Medium sich diese Art vererbt, falls tatsächlich mal Medien, andere Medien ablösen. Machen sie ja zum Glück nicht. Aber da ging ja dann wirklich was verloren.
Männer lesen ja tatsächlich mehr Sachbücher, als sie schön geistige Literatur lesen. Und sicherlich reden wir jetzt sehr instrumentell generell über Literatur. Man kann jetzt auch sagen, Literatur ist Literatur. Sie steht für sich, la polla, und die muss nicht da sein, umzu. Und das ist auch irgendwo richtig. Aber dennoch kann man ja auch wieder was für sich ableiten, auch etwas Funktionales durchaus darin erkennen. Und ich finde diesen Punkt, den Franziskus bringt, ganz entscheidend. Warum soll ich denn mir eine ausgedachte Geschichte durchlesen? Wenn ich über Literatur nachdenke, fällt mir ein, was der große argentinische Schriftsteller Jorge Luis Borges seinen Studenten zu sagen pflegte. Das Wichtigste ist, zu lesen, in direkten Kontakt mit der Literatur zu kommen, in den lebendigen Text vor uns einzutauchen, anstatt sich auf Ideen und kritische Kommentare zu fixieren. Und Borges erklärte seinen Schülern diese Idee, indem er ihnen sagte, dass sie vielleicht zunächst wenig von dem, was sie lesen, verstehen würden, aber dass sie auf jeden Fall die Stimme von jemandem hören würden. Das ist eine Definition von Literatur, die mir sehr gefällt, die Stimme von jemandem hören. Und vergessen wir nicht, wie gefährlich es ist, nicht mehr auf die Stimmen des anderen zu hören, der uns befragt. Wir fallen sofort in die Selbstisolierung. Wir geraten in eine Art geistige Taubheit.
Ja, das ist interessant. Also über die Stille werden wir gleich noch reden. Nun ist es ja so. Ich lese ja nicht, indem ich jetzt ein Buch aufschlage und auf Papier gedruckte Buchstaben über meine Augen konsumiere.
Wer würde an sowas denken?
Ich setze mir Kopfhörer auf, ich gehe in den Wald, ich blicke ins Grün und höre ein Buch. Und jetzt sagt Reese Witherspoon zum Beispiel, die ja nun sehr viel Erfolg damit hat, das Buch wieder dem Publikum zuzuführen. Klar, das ist auch Lesen. Also niemand muss sich dafür entschuldigen, ein Buch nur gehört zu haben. Trotzdem, egal, auch wenn man heute bei irgendwelche Apps synthetische Stimmen hat, die Stimme bringt Stimmung mit, die eigentlich der Text noch nicht hergibt. Also die eigentlich auf Seiten des Lesers erst entstehen muss.
Es ist eine Interpretation. Genau.
Und das, also bei Sachbüchern kann man das ein bisschen ausblenden, bei Romanen nicht. Und das finde ich wirklich interessant, ob man jetzt mich noch mal zum Romaneleser macht, wenn ich jetzt mir über die Sachbuchlektüre schon so ein neues Leseverhalten antrainiert habe, bei dem die Stimme eben eigentlich nicht wirklich wegzudenken ist.
Also ich genieße das ja dann keine Stimme zu hören, sondern bei mir, ich höre auch Hörbücher natürlich und finde, das war manchmal sehr schön ein Buch, das ich gelesen habe, noch mal mir anzuhören. Ich höre mir beispielsweise dann auf Englisch noch mal The Shards von Pratt Easton Ellis an, habe es dann auf Deutsch schon vorher gelesen. Aber es ist doch eher so, dass ich die Literatur auch lesen will und will diese Stimmenvielfalt, die man dort erlebt, und auch selbst in meinem Kopf entstehen lassen. Was ja noch wichtig ist für Franziskus, ist, dass wir durch die Literatur andere Bewertungsmaßstäbe bekommen oder dass wir in einer Welt, in der wir sehr schnell urteilen, natürlich differenzierter vielleicht auf die Welt blicken könnten, dadurch, dass wir Texte gelesen haben, in denen uns andere Lebenswelten, andere Figuren begegnen. Es ist notwendig, zu aufnehmenden, nicht strategischen, nicht direkt auf ein Ergebnis ausgerichteten Formen der Beziehung zur Wirklichkeit zurückzufinden, in denen es möglich ist, den unendlichen Überfluss des Seins hervortreten zu lassen. Distanz, Langsamkeit, Freiheit sind die Merkmale einer Annäherung an die Wirklichkeit, die gerade in der Literatur eine vielleicht nicht exklusive, aber doch bevorzugte Ausdrucksform findet. Die Literatur wird dann zu einem Übungsort, in dem der Blick geschult wird, um die Wahrheit der Menschen und Situationen als Geheimnis zu suchen und zu erforschen, als Reich an einem Übermaß an Bedeutung, das sich nur teilweise in Kategorien, Erklärungsschemata, in einer linearen Dynamik von Ursache, Wirkung, Mittel, Zweck manifestieren kann. Nehmen wir ein ganz konkretes Beispiel. Wenn im Freundeskreis irgendetwas ist mit Betrug, Fremdgene etc., dann sind ja immer sehr schnell Lagerbildungen zu erleben.
Wie oft erlebst du sowas denn?
Urteile sind stark gesprochen. Ich habe lustre Freunde.
Was ist denn los in Koblenz?
Ja, ich bin natürlich immer wohl anständig, aber die anderen nicht.
Deswegen wirst du immer zuerst angerufen.
Ich hatte mal ein schönes Gespräch mit einer Dame vom Richard-Wagner-Verband. Wir waren in Düsseldorf und wir standen draußen vor der Oper, rauchten eine Zigarette und sie sagte, hier hatte ich vor vielen Jahren mal eine Affäre mit einem Mann. Da habe ich doch auch Schlimmes gesagt, ich habe mich schlecht gefühlt und so. Und dann mit einem verheirateten Mann, dann sagte ich, naja gut, das ist ja eher die Schuld des Mannes. Und dann sagte sie, nein, nein, ich war ja auch verheiratet. Und dann erlebt man so einiges. Wie gesagt, wir sind da manchmal mit den Urteilen schnell, lesen dann aber natürlich so etwas wie Madame Bovary. Da geht es auch um Ehebruch. Und plötzlich sehen wir die Sache so viel vielschichtiger, so differenzierter, wie wir das in unserem eigenen Leben auch oft gar nicht hinkriegen oder gar nicht hinbekommen wollen. Und deswegen würde ich jetzt einen letzten Clip von Franziskus spielen und auch bei aller Freude, die er an der Literatur hat und die ich auch teile, doch ein Fragezeichen setzen, ob diese Lektüre, Erfahrung, die man macht, einen dann wirklich dazu befähigt, anders zu sehen bzw. feinfühlig zu werden. Wenn wir inmitten dieser Geschichten Spuren unserer inneren Welt finden, werden wir feinfühliger für die Erfahrungen der anderen. Wir treten aus uns heraus, um in ihre Tiefen einzudringen. Wir können ihre Kämpfe und Sehnsüchte ein wenig besser verstehen. Wir sehen die Wirklichkeit mit ihren Augen und werden schließlich zu Weggefährten. So tauchen wir ein in die konkrete innere Existenz des Obstverkäufers, der Prostituierten, des Kindes, das ohne die Eltern aufwächst, der Frau, des Maurers, der alten Frau, die immer noch glaubt, ihren Prinzen zu finden. Und wir können dies mit Einfühlungsvermögen und manchmal mit Duldsamkeit und Verständnis tun. Möge er recht haben, aber wir müssen das, glaube ich, mit unserem Gast besprechen. Ob wir feinfühliger werden. Es sind sogar beide da.
Gasten sind sogar da.
Prima.
Ja, während ich unsere Gäste vorstelle. Wolfgang hat hier noch, also du hast ja nicht nur den großen Papst, sondern auch den Papst des kleinen Mannes mitgebracht.
Also Andrew Tate sagt bei Twitter, Reading books is for losers who are afraid to learn from life. Und dann erzählt er uns nochmal, books are a total waste of time. Also nur das Leben kann einem etwas lernen. Da würde ich sagen, naja, Andrew Tate widerlegt es ja in seinem ganzen Dasein. Da hätte vielleicht ein Buch schon mal gut getan. Vor allem vielleicht auch mal von einer Frau geschrieben, dass man da mal eine andere Perspektive bekommt. Aber vielleicht ist der auch nicht mit Büchern mehr zu retten. Jedenfalls diese Ansicht gibt es auch.
Ja, also der große Papst ist klüger. Es gibt keine große Unterscheidung zwischen Lesen und Leben. Lesen ist das Leben. Ich habe vor Urzeiten mal im FAZ Vöhtor eine ganze Seite über ausgedachte Wirklichkeiten geschrieben, die mit der Frage, die Franziskus hier auch aufwarf, zu lesen. Und in dem Moment, wie Anne Tootel sagt, nicht zu leben, kann einen tatsächlich näher an die Realität heranführen als Geschichten, die man von vor Jahrzehnten von Frauen, die sie vielleicht zum ersten Mal erzählen, dann so im wahren Leben hört. Und aus diesem FAZ Vöhtor, sie schreibt dort seit Ewigkeiten und war letztes Jahr sogar Jurymitglied des Deutschen Buchpreises. Sie kann uns also gleich aufklären darüber, was für ein Hauen und Stechen und es ist am Ende doch alles Politik, dort stattfindet. Geschrieben hat sie selbst bisher über Menschen am Berg, Familien, Klammer auf in zerrütteten Zuständen, Klammer zu, Jugendliche, die gerade so 15 sind und sagen wir mal die praktische Empathie, nämlich das Mitfühlen. Wir haben es ja gerade gehört und wir warten auf ihren ersten Roman. Melanie Mühl ist hier, kommt zu uns. Und wir warten auf ein zweites Roman-Debüt von Elena Witzeck auch aus dem F.A.Z-Föter.
Jetzt haben wir das wirkliche Frankfurt auf der Bühne, FAZ. Jetzt wird es also hochkulturell oder wie müssen wir uns das vorstellen? Wie läuft das bei euch ab? Bei euch wird noch viel gelesen in der Redaktion oder mogelt man sich auch schon durch mit Kurzzusammenfassungen bei TikTok?
Nö, wir sind jetzt auch eher bei TikTok.
Wir lesen schon brav noch, ja.
Ist es anstrengend zu lesen?
Überhaupt nicht. Es sind viel anstrengendere Dinge.
Also lesen? Wem fallen beim Lesen die Augen zu? Macht es das Lesen anstrengend?
Kommt natürlich auf die Uhrzeit an. Also um diese Uhrzeit schlafen wir ja normalerweise schon.
Absolut, ja.
Aber so am frühen Abend kann man wunderbar lesen.
Das ist sicherlich schon ein sehr wichtiger Hinweis, die Uhrzeit ist entscheidend. Wo liest man? Ich zum Beispiel lese nie im Bett. Ich lese immer eigentlich nur am Schreibtisch. Manchmal auf dem Sofa, aber dann habe ich wirklich so einen Schluffi-Tag. Aber ich lese eigentlich am Schreibtisch und da wird man auch nicht so müde. Ich empfehle sowieso, um besser einschlafen zu können. Viele Leute haben ja mit dem Schlafen Probleme. Man sollte das Bett nur zum Schlafnutzen. Also ich weiß, es gibt noch andere Dinge, aber man sollte es primär zum Schlafnutzen und Lesen ist gar nicht gut im Bett.
Aber versuch doch mal einen Stehpult, vielleicht kannst du da lesen.
Hab ich auch.
Und?
Ja, ich wackele so ein bisschen hin und her, aber generell ist die Technik nicht schlecht mit Stehpult.
Badewanne?
Ist zu feucht, ist ganz schlecht für die Bücher. Ich bin ja auch Biprionophil, da soll ja nicht so viel dran kommen.
Also ich schreibe nicht mal am Schreibtisch und lesen. Das ist völlig Outer Space, was Wolfgang da erzählt.
Aber um nicht gleich ganz so persönlich zu werden, wenn ihr jetzt Föjeton macht, dann spielt die Literatur ja im F.A.Z-Föjeton immer noch eine sehr wichtige Rolle. Da gibt es die Seite 2, dort erscheinen mehrere Rezensionen. Zudem wird Überlesung Literaturfestivals berichtet oder auch, wenn dann ein Roman einen Trend auslöst oder eine Debatte, dann kommt das auch auf die erste Föjeton-Seite und dann gibt es einen Literaturstreit oder was auch immer, einen Kritikerstreit. Hat die Literatur einen inzwischen anderen Stellenwert? Ist sie weniger wichtig geworden, wenn ihr jetzt so die letzten, sagen wir, fünf oder zehn Jahre noch mal Revue passieren lasst?
Also ich würde nicht sagen, dass sie weniger wichtig geworden ist. Ich würde sagen, sie ist auf eine andere Art und Weise wichtig geworden. Es wird ja nach wie vor die Literaturhäuser sind voll. Man hatte ja nach der Pandemie Angst, dass die Gäste wegbleiben, die Literaturinteressierten wegbleiben. Aber es ist ja auch gar nicht der Fall. Wenn man sich die Zahlen anguckt, was die Lesenden betrifft, sind die jetzt auch nicht so dramatisch. Ich habe hier mal geguckt von Allensbach. Am wenigsten lesen die Senioren. Das hat mich ein bisschen schockiert, weil ich eigentlich dachte, die hätten viel Zeit. Aber offenbar kommen sie nicht zum Lesen. Nur 17 % der befragten Senioren haben gesagt, dass sie viel lesen, also mehrmals pro Monat. Bei den Jugendlichen waren es 35 %. Was sich natürlich verändert hat, ist die Rezeption von Literatur und natürlich auch die Bedeutung des Literaturkritikers, weil es natürlich viele andere Kanäle jetzt gibt, wo sich die Menschen informieren, was soll ich lesen, was ist gut, was ist schlecht, was sagen eigentlich meine Freunde, brauche ich den Literaturkritiker noch? Der Saal, in dem wir sitzen, ist ja glaube ich der Reich-Ranitzki-Saal, wenn ich das richtig gelesen habe. Es wäre interessant, was er dazu zu sagen hätte als Großkritiker. Das ist natürlich etwas, glaube ich, was der Kritiker-Seele weh tut. Ich finde es interessant, dass es auch da, was die Kritik betrifft, eine neue Vielstimmigkeit gibt. Und trotzdem ist es natürlich immer noch nicht ganz unwichtig, was in den Zeitungen steht, oder Elena?
Ja, wir haben natürlich den Vorteil, du hast es schon erwähnt, Wolfgang, dass wir die Seite 2 noch haben und damit relativ viele Rezensionen. Andere Zeitungen haben ja ziemlich abgespeckt, was das angeht. Und da hören wir immer noch von den Verlagen als Rückmeldung, dass es sich natürlich schon lohnt, wenn dann so was in der Zeitung steht oder im Internet, weil es eine Auswirkung hat auf die Verkaufszahlen. Und dann gibt es natürlich die Möglichkeit, über Artikel auch literarisch zu transportieren. Also man bezieht sich ja nicht nur in eine Rezension auf Literatur, sondern auch bei ganz vielen anderen Themen, wo man dann vielleicht irgendwie feststellt, da lässt sich ein Bezug herstellen. Und ich lese solche Artikel immer ziemlich gerne, weil ich dann so was mir rausschreibe und dann selbst mir noch mal ein Buch besorge, was da vielleicht erwähnt wurde.
Und wenn man sich überlegt, was soll ich als Nächstes lesen? Also ich glaube, wir lesen relativ viel. Also weil es einfach Spaß macht. Wir sind jetzt beide gar nicht in der Literaturredaktion fest verankert und rezensieren, aber hin und wieder.
Melanie schreibt mir immer irgendwelche Mails, jetzt kommt demnächst das neue Buch so und so raus. Und dann holt sie sich die Fahne immer als Erste. Und dann liest sie es schon durch. Und dann bin ich immer viel zu spät dran und ärgere mich.
Ich gucke zum Beispiel total gerne, finde ich wirklich gut, auf die SWR besten Liste. Und da kannst du auch mal drauf gucken, Stefan. Da steht so hin und wieder irgendwie was ganz Witziges. Vielleicht, wenn du einfach mal so die Appetizer liest, so Leseproben gibt es ja. Also du fängst klein an und arbeitest dich dann hoch.
Ich habe mich gerade noch gefragt, was war eigentlich das zweite Buch, was du gelesen hast, außer Grabert?
Also ich habe damals The Circle von Dave Eggers für die Zeitung geschrieben. Ich wollte quasi meinen Chef beeindrucken, habe es deswegen schnell gelesen und besprochen. Und nur weil ich es besprochen habe, habe ich es durchgelesen. Sonst hätte ich es wahrscheinlich auch nicht durchgelesen. Ich weiß noch, zu meiner Zeit damals hatten wir einen Reader-Scan für die ganze Zeitung. Und da kam eine Debatte auf beim Thema Rezension von dem, über das wir eben sprachen, also Bühnenrealität und so. Schreibt man eigentlich für die Menschen, die da noch hingehen, damit sie wissen, was einen erwartet? Oder bespricht man irgendwelche Sachen, die in Paris und London Premieren haben, um hier nochmal zu vergegenwärtigen, wohin der Leser eh nicht fährt, weil es zu weit weg ist? Und irgendwie gab es diese Diskussion aber bei den Büchern nicht. Also, dass man Bücher bespricht für Menschen, die nur wissen wollen, was gerade aktuell ist, aber nicht das Buch lesen werden. Was ja den Kritiker in diese Rolle versetzt, selber sozusagen Miniliteratur zu machen. Das haben wir heute ausgelagert an Algorithmen, also Claude fasst uns irgendwas zusammen. Oder wir haben diese Blinkist-App, die auch überall beworben wird, wo du jedes Buch innerhalb von 15 Minuten konsumieren kannst.
Das sind aber Sachbücher, ne?
Ja, genau, das sind eben Sachbücher. Und jetzt ist ja die Frage, könnte man das nicht für Romane auch machen, sodass ich einfach die Longlist und die Shortlist kenne, ohne mich stundenlang?
Du willst hier einfach gar nicht lesen, ne?
Ich würde aber trotzdem gerne wissen, sind sie gut, was erwartet mich für ein Stil, worüber kann ich reden, wenn mich jemand anspricht?
Das ist halt eine andere Lesetradition. Ich meine, entweder man liest, weil man es genießt. Also es ist ja ein Genuss, zu lesen.
Ich glaube, du hast das Konzept von Lesen nicht verstanden.
Kann sein, kann sein. Vielleicht finde ich auch zu viele der Opa.
Aber vielleicht solltest du mehr so Brigitte oder so lesen. Da gibt es jetzt immer diese Kurzrezension, wo man einfach direkt sieht, worum geht es und das Wesentliche ist dann auch zusammengefasst.
Und warum macht das F.A.Z-Filter und das nicht?
So ganz kleine für Stefan, zusammengefasst.
Die Zeitung macht das ja auch für Kinofilme. Zwei Zeiler, wo kurz erwähnt wird, launig.
Na ja, so Kinofilme sind ja schnell geguckt. Man sieht die Woche als Filmkritiker fünf Filme. Und zwei davon sind nicht jetzt nötig groß zu besprechen. Und dann verwertet man das noch in so einer Kurzkritik vielleicht gerade. Bei einem Roman ist das schon anders. Man setzt sich nicht hin, liest 400 Seiten. Um dann in zwei Zeilen zu schreiben, war ganz gut.
Aber auch das passiert inzwischen. Also wir haben wirklich Glück, aber in anderen Medien ist es teilweise so.
Ja, ja. Ich meine, die Süddeutsche macht das mitunter auch so, so kürzeste Kritiken. Ich glaube, das führt dann nicht so weit. Und es geht ja nicht darum, dass man mal erfährt, worum es darin geht. Ich erinnere mich da, ich hatte das schon mal irgendwann erzählt, an eine ehemalige Mitschülerin, die ich traf, die mich fragte, was ich mache. Und ich sage, Filmkritiker. Und dann sagte sie, ja, das könnte sie mit den Filmen gar nicht verstehen. Denn man würde ja die Inhaltsangaben zu den Filmen schließlich im Internet finden. Warum würde man sich die nochmal ansehen? Und es geht ja nicht um einen Inhalt. Also es ist ja nicht die Frage, wie bringt sich Madame Bouvierie um? Zu wissen, dass sie sich umbringt, ist nicht unwichtig. Aber warum? Welche Gesellschaft wird mir da eigentlich gezeigt? Und wie stand die Sonne? Wie strahlte das Gras im Regen? Das ist etwas, was man wissen möchte. Und deswegen ist das ja eigentlich eine Form der Vertiefung. Und wenn wir jetzt mal überlegen, was machen wir die ganze Zeit? Also junge Leute sind 7, 8 Stunden mit Bildschirm am Tag vernetzen. Da ist noch nicht die Schulzeit mit dazu. Wenn die älter werden, dann nimmt das eher sogar noch zu. Also es nimmt nicht ab, es sei dann, man ist beruflich zu sehr eingebunden. Und dann funktionieren doch Instagram, Twitter, Facebook und alles über vier Faktoren. Also einmal, man hat ein Profil, ein eigenes, man hat Interaktivität, man hat so ein Netzwerk, mit dem man kommuniziert und es ist sehr viel user-generated content. Und diese vier Faktoren sind ja genau das, was man, wenn man ein Buch liest, nicht antreffen kann. Und das ist ja schon mal so was Fundamentales, dass man eine absolute Gegenwelt hat. Weshalb es auch, glaube ich, relativ schwierig ist, erst mal in diese Gegenwelt reinzukommen, weil es näher liegt irgendwas mit einem Profil und Interaktivität zu machen.
Ich bin überzeugt.
Stefan, wenn du eine Zusammenfassung liest, wirst du natürlich nie anfangen zu weinen bei einem Buch.
Das ist ein sehr guter Punkt.
Wenn du das Buch ganz liest, dann kann es vielleicht passieren, dass dir die Tränen kommen. Wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht bei den ersten drei, die du liest, aber wenn du so eine gewisse Übung dir erarbeitet hast.
Aber klar, beim literarischen Kanon kann man es natürlich nutzen, um zu posen, wenn man dann einfach die Zusammenfassung gelesen hat und am Tag nur unterwegs ist.
Ich bin total überzeugt davon. Ihr habt mich überzeugt. Ich will nicht groß davon ablenken, sondern kleine Transferleistungen. Die Fragen von eben sind ja, finde ich, auch beim Lesen interessant. Was ziehe ich an, wenn ich lese? Und wie verhalte ich mich, wenn ich lese? Ich habe hier etwas ganz Interessantes gefunden. Ihr habt vielleicht gemerkt, ihr habt kein Internet hier im Saal, also Instagram nur über mich. Dieser Typ hier lässt sich ansprechen in einem leicht gestellten Gespräch. Aber er hat ein ganz interessantes Accessoire dabei. Ich habe das zum ersten Mal gesehen und ich war auch sofort überzeugt.
Hi, excuse me, can I ask you a question? Yeah. Can you tell me about your book holder?
Oh yeah, absolutely. So I got this from Resid Journals.
Super cool.
This allows me to carry my books wherever I go. So for a good lover like myself, it's really awesome. It also holds my place.
It just slips on really, really easily.
Oh nice. I love it.
How does it hold it?
It holds it with this little place marker here.
Alles lese, zeichne ist auch gleich.
Thank you so much.
Man trägt jetzt das Buch als Tasche und hat es einfach so locker um die Seite gehangen.
Ich kriege ja immer mal wieder E-Mails mit dem Wortlaut, Wolfgang hat Geburtstag, was kann ich ihm bloß schenken? Du hast doch viel mit ihm zu tun. Und dann schreibe ich, ich weiß es auch nicht. Ich werde jetzt so oft auf dieses Video verweisen, bis wir alle Wolfgang irgendwann mit so einem Ding sehen. Dahingeschlendert in die Käse.
Schön. Ja.
So, und jetzt das, was Melanie gerade aufgeworfen hat. Wie verhält man sich beim Lesen in der Öffentlichkeit? Ich habe dieses sehr niedliche Video gefunden. Das wirklich Rührende hier ist, sie hat es gerade zu Ende gelesen. Das war die letzte Seite.
Jetzt ist sie aufgelöst.
Ja, sie wurde von dem Buch in diesem emotionalen Zustand verfrachtet und muss jetzt ohne das Buch wieder heraus.
Und steckt mit anderen noch im Flugzeug.
Sitzt sie da im Zug oder so? Genau.
Aber vielleicht hat sie auch wahnsinnige Flugangst. Wir wissen es nicht.
Nee, ich glaube, das ist ein Zug. Ich glaube, es ist ein Zug. Zug? Ja, das Gepäck liegt oben so ein bisschen locker, oder? Stimmt, sie hat mehr Beinfreiheit.
Stimmt, ein Zug.
Aber das ist ja wirklich interessant. Also wir haben das ja eben schon besprochen. Sie hat einfach gelesen. Sie hat sich es nicht vorlesen lassen. Also hier hat keine Stimme, irgendeine Stimmung vorgegeben, sondern sie hat einfach sozusagen die Partitur vor sich gehabt. Kein Orchester hat gespielt und trotzdem hat sie es so mitgerissen. Und das ist eigentlich diese Frage. Also ich habe jetzt so lange keine Romane gelesen, aber ich weiß genau, was ich sollte. Und trotzdem fehlt irgendwie so ein Kicker, obwohl unendlich viele Bücher... Wem geht es eigentlich genauso? Es werden so krass viele Bücher geschrieben und man denkt sich, in irgendeines müsste man sich mal stürzen. Es sind so ein paar, nicht allzu viele. Aber irgendwo ist da noch so ein Stolperstein, der mich immer wieder aus der Bahn wirft.
Ich denke, dass es schon auch mit Überwindung manchmal zu tun hat. Also ihr habt jetzt auch nochmal sehr betont, wie viel Vergnügen Lesen bereiten kann. Und das stimmt absolut, so sehe ich das auch. Aber ich glaube, schon in so einer Dopamin-Kultur, in der man sich befindet mit sehr vielen schnellen Reizen, ist also diese Art der Vertiefung, die es verlangt. Und dass man dann auch nichts anderes nebenbei machen kann. Also da gibt es nicht Second Screen oder so. Ist das doch immer mehr eine Herausforderung, also diese Überwindung zu machen? Und ich würde auch sagen, seitdem ich mehr mit den sozialen Medien zu tun habe, muss ich mich mehr davon auch exakt abkoppeln, um dann diese Lesezeit zu haben. Und das berichten mir relativ viele. Geht euch das auch so? Oder sagt ihr, ich kann den 300 Seiten Roman in einem Rutsch durchlesen, neben mir liegt mein Smartphone, das meldet sich zwar, aber ich gucke nicht drauf.
Es kommt wahrscheinlich darauf an, wie viel Anlass man zur Flucht hat. Wenn ich zurückdenke, wir beide sind in der Zeit groß geworden, in der es eben noch nicht so viele Ablenkungen gab. Und wenn man mal in einem langweiligen Familienurlaub war oder Langeweile kennengelernt hat in der Familie, zu Hause, in der Umgebung, haben wir jetzt viele auch über Corona in der Pandemie erlebt, dann sucht man ja so Fluchtmöglichkeiten. Und ich finde, das sind jetzt eine der besten Fluchtmöglichkeiten. Es kommt natürlich sehr darauf an, was man liest. Ich breche auch rigoros ab, wenn ich mich für was nicht interessiere oder feststelle, dass es nichts für mich ist. Weil ich einfach zu wenig Zeit hätte, alles durchzulesen, dann fange ich mit was Neuem an.
Ich merke schon, dass ich es schwierig finde, mich zu konzentrieren. Ich lege dann das Handy weg und lasse mich auch nicht ablenken, mache es auch leise und so. Aber beim Buchpreis, da muss ich ja wirklich extrem viel lesen. Also gewissermaßen fast das ganze Jahr nonstop. Und eben auch viel, was man dann zwar abbrechen kann, weil man merkt, das ist einfach schlecht, das hat ohnehin keine Chance. Aber viele Dinge, auch die einen so mittelmäßig interessieren und wo man aber natürlich auch unsicher ist, ist es nur, weil mir jetzt der Stil persönlich nicht gefällt. Das ist ja natürlich auch was sehr Subjektives. Ob einem der Roman, in welcher Situation man ihn liest, an wen die Protagonisten erinnern und so weiter. Ich habe schon gemerkt, dass ich das auch wieder ein bisschen lernen musste. Fand es dann aber schön, weil Lesen ja auch was damit zu tun hat, dass man die eigene Sprache auch trainiert und das eigene Sprache empfinden. Und das finde ich schon was Schönes.
Also du warst letztes Jahr in der Jury des Buchpreises. Die wird ja jedes Jahr neu besetzt, damit es da zu ordentlichen Verwirbelungen kommt. Sieben Leute oder so kriegen dann den Auftrag, wie viele Bücher zu sichten. Also alle Einreichungen oder was? Wie läuft das ab?
Also dieses Jahr wurden glaube ich knapp 200 Bücher eingereicht. Das dürfen ja alle Verlage einreichen. Und wir hatten auch 180 Bücher. Das wird dann durch das Zufallprinzip aufgeteilt auf die sieben Leute und dann gibt es so eine Excel-Tabelle. Und wir haben es so gemacht. Wir haben unsere Eindrücke von den Büchern, die man lesen musste, reingeschrieben. Und es konnte aber auch jeder der Jurorin sagen, dieses Buch interessiert mich. Da glaube ich nicht, was Melanie jetzt sagt. Da vertraue ich ihr Mutter nicht. Den Autor kenne ich. Ich gucke da auch rein und habe da vielleicht eine andere Meinung dazu. Man kann auch 170 Bücher lesen, wenn man möchte.
Genau, wenn man jeden eine Chance geben will, 180. Aber selbst die, die man dann pflichtteilmäßig zugeteilt bekommt, das bedeutet ja schon, man braucht eine Methode. Irgend so ein Scan, keine Ahnung. Man gibt jetzt jedem Buch zehn Seiten und dann muss es funken oder?
Also meinst du, so mal schnell durchflottern, weg.
Das ist aber das, was die Lektoren sagen. In den ersten zehn Seiten sollte man eigentlich so gecatcht sein, dass man weiter lesen kann.
Ja, also ich glaube schon, dass man, wenn man so ein bisschen Gefühl hat. Manchmal ist, bin ich ja, natürlich ist man unsicher. Ja, das sind Leute, die unfassbar viel Arbeit in so einen Roman gesteckt haben, den möchten, das reichen ihnen einen für den Buchpreis. Und ich möchte denen nicht einfach dann vom Tisch wehen und sagen, dieser Roman hat keine Chance, es sei denn natürlich, er hat wirklich keine Chance und ist sehr schlecht. Dann schon. Aber es gibt eben auch so, natürlich frage ich dann, hey, könnt ihr mal reinlesen? Für mich ist das jetzt zu experimentell. Ich mag es eher so ein bisschen simpel vielleicht. Wo ist denn da die Love Story? Oder das ist mir nicht spannend genug. Oder hier finde ich die Sprache so ein bisschen aufgesetzt. Dann fragt man natürlich nach. Aber man muss es wirklich ernsthaft lesen. Ich habe jeden Abend ungefähr drei Stunden, also ungelogen. Gut, ich habe eh kein Sozialleben, aber da hatte ich auch keins mehr.
Man geht mit der Erwartung rein, dass durchaus ab Seite 100 noch Leser bewegendes passieren kann, wenn es vorher nicht funktioniert hat. Weil meine Erwartung wäre so, nach den ersten zehn Seiten ist zumindest schon mal die Sprache gesetzt. Das wäre ganz gut.
Hast du Herr der Ringe nie gelesen? Die ersten 100 Seiten, Tolkien.
Tolkien, nein.
Ich aber auch nicht.
Wenn man sich da nicht durchkämpft, liest man ja nie weiter.
Ich weiß noch, Harry Potter hatte ja, der Band eins hat es ja schwer, das so sagt die Legende. Es waren nicht die ersten Verlage, die dazu gegriffen haben. Als ich es dann selber las, habe ich mir gedacht, ja, die ersten 60 Seiten sind auch nicht repräsentativ für das, was dann kommt.
Wollte ja niemand Harry Potter. Hat dann der Verleger dem Sohn vorgelesen als gute Nachtgeschichte. Der Sohn hat gesagt, finde ich mega. Und dann hat er es eingekauft.
Das finde ich so erstaunlich, dass so ein Text sich dann doch nochmal verändern kann. Und dass er selbst bei Profilesern so unterschiedlich funktioniert. Also diese Geschichten kennt man ja sonst nur von Deutschlehrern. Dass man so zufallsprinzipmäßig mal die Qualität des Unterrichts nach Lehrerleistungen abfragt. Dann hat man Aufsätze und dann werden alle Noten gegeben. Also jeder Lehrer gibt irgendwelche Noten und es ist nicht so, dass die Guten alle in Einzelnen und dann rotiert es durch, sondern es werden wild durcheinander fast nach Zufallsprinzip da Noten vergeben. Und wenn ich jetzt wüsste, ich hätte 35 Bücher auf dem Tisch, die ich irgendwie danach bewerten muss, ob ich das jetzt in der Jury weiterreiche oder nicht, es wäre eine mich sozusagen überfordernde Aufgabe, glaube ich. Ich könnte mich dem nicht stellen. So wie ich ja auch jetzt schon feststelle, dass mich ein einzelnes Buch überfordert, was ich irgendwie skandalös finde, aber es ist normal.
Aber ist es bei dir die Angst vor der Fiktion? Weil du bist ja in der Lage, Bücher zu lesen, selbst jene, die dir nicht so gut gefallen, sprich, die ich ausgewählt habe für den Salon. Und dennoch hast du bei der Fiktion so eine Schranke.
Also ich glaube Stefan braucht so einen Anlass. Irgendjemand muss ihm sagen, das musst du unbedingt gelesen haben dann.
Also wenn ich weiß, wir reden drüber oder ich schreibe darüber, ist das ein Selbstläufer. Also dann verbuche ich das als Arbeitszeit und dann hängt da auch ein Kassenzettel dran, eine Rechnung sozusagen. Ich weiß noch, als ich damals The Circle gelesen habe, ich bin darauf aufmerksam geworden, weil der Autor schon in Kreisen im Internet, die ich interessant fand, besprochen wurde vorher. Er hat sehr persönliche Familiengeschichten geschrieben. Und dann hat er sich dem Silicon Valley zugewandt und hat, weil ihm Empirie fehlte, kein Sachbuch geschrieben, aber ein aufgrund von Arbeitsethos, Ideologie, was auch immer so Zeitgeist war, ein Roman, von dem ich wusste, das spiegelt wieder. Das heißt, nicht ohne Grund The Circle und das Apple Campus Ding wurde gerade gebaut. Und man wusste eigentlich, ist das Google, was er da beschreibt und so weiter und so fort. Also es hatte sozusagen eine Nähe zum empirischen Kern, der es interessant gemacht hat. Nur diese Romanwelt, so wie ich das verstehe, also gerade wenn ich jetzt an Krabbart denke. Krabbart ist ein Buch, das wurde mir in der Schule vorgelesen, vom Lehrer abends auf Klassenfahrt. Also wir saßen in sozialer Runde, sollten alle still sein, da wurde Krabbart vorgelesen. Und heute lese ich es immer wieder und ich denke dann immer so ein bisschen an dieses Phänomen beim Film. Wenn man Kindern einen Film anmacht, müssen sie den Film schon kennen. Den Film zum 80. Mal schauen, kein Problem. Die Kinder wissen, was sie erwartet. Sie wollen es einfach erleben. Einen neuen Film vorschlagen, super schwer und das greift da auch immer wieder. Selbst, wenn mir empfohlen wird, hier liest auch mal diese Reihe oder wie auch immer, da kann man sich reinfühlen, rein nerden, was auch immer. Ich lese das dann und erkenne die Welt einfach nicht und will hier dann auch nicht zu viel Zeit rein investieren, um sie kennenzulernen.
Ich hoffe, du bist sehr in dieser Kosten-Nutzen-Kalkulation drin. Eigentlich ist die Literatur etwas, was einen daraus ausbrechen lässt. Und selbst wenn man dann für den deutschen Buchpreis so viel lesen muss, muss man sicherlich auch mit einem gewissen Effizienzgedanken herangehen und muss auch ein bisschen kalkuliert herangehen, weil man fertig werden muss. Und man kann sich nur nicht dem Schöngeistigen verlieren, sondern muss auch liefern, was in eine Excel-Tabelle eintragen, was eigentlich Literatur ist. Aber dennoch sind dann ja diese Räume, die sich eröffnen, die jenseits des Instrumentellen, des Nützlichen sich auf tun. Und das ist ja eigentlich auch dieser utopische Ort, der sich dann zwischen diesen beiden Buchdeckeln so merkwürdig öffnet für einen. Und das ist das, was mich fasziniert. Und dann auch diese Doppelseitigkeit davon, dass man zum einen eine Vielstimmigkeit in Romanen in der Regel hat. Also viele Figuren sprechen, ihre Perspektiven werden beschrieben. Vielleicht ist es auch ein polyperspektivischer Roman. Und sogleich ist es aber in aller Regel das Werk einer einzigen Person. Also ganz anders als jetzt beim Film, wo so viele mitwirken oder auch bei der Oper. Und ich will jetzt nicht einen Geniekult betreiben. Und ich weiß auch, dass Geschriebenes schon auf vorhergeschriebenen basiert in gewisser Weise. Und man sollte aber dennoch dieses Palimpsest-artige nicht zu stark machen. Es gibt diese Subjektivität auch desjenigen, der schreibt. Und dass sich das dann so verbindet mit meiner eigenen Subjektivität des Lesens, das ist eigentlich ein magisches Verhältnis, ein eigenartiger Pakt, der sich der Bild, den man dann noch aufkündigen kann, wenn es nicht gefällt. Aber das ist eigentlich, was mich fortwährend an der Literatur so fasziniert.
Und das ist ja das, was einen manchmal auch so entzaubert, wenn man damit den Autoren zu tun hat.
Großer Fehler.
Fühlt man Gespräche und denkt so, oh nein, das war alles ganz anders gemeint.
Deshalb doch lieber tote Autoren.
Ja, sag mal, es gibt ja einen gewissen Trend schon im Kulturjournalismus, ich will das jetzt nicht auf die FAZ müssen, sondern im Allgemeinen, dass man erkennen kann, wenn die Person, die das Buch geschrieben hat, interessant ist, dann ist nicht mehr mit Tod des Autors und was weiß ich alles, dann ist poststrukturalismus erledigt. Dann trifft man sich, reist nochmal die Orte des Romans nach, darf auch nochmal der bösen Schwiegermutter die Hand schütteln, was auch immer. Also dann ist plötzlich so Personality, fast möchte ich sagen, Home-Story angesagt. Woher kommt dieser Trend? Warum wird das auch so geschätzt? Denn das ist für mich, also für mich waren das früher, das Einzige, was ich mir ansah, waren diese alljährlichen Besuche. Martin Walzer am Bodensee zeigt nochmal, dass er immer noch schwimmen kann. Aber sonst ging es bei mir nie darüber hinaus. Aber die Faszination bei den Abonnenten oder auch den Lesern allgemein scheint ja groß für sowas zu sein.
Also meine ist ziemlich gering, aber...
Das literarische Leben war immer ein großer... Das literarische Leben war ja immer ein F.A.Z-Teil. Hat auch Schirrmacher immer interessiert. Was ist hinter dem Buch noch los?
Aber wahrscheinlich dann, man erhofft sich natürlich dann auch, dass dann im Gespräch, im Kontakt mit dem Autor, der Autorin irgendwas Besonderes passiert, was vielleicht nicht unbedingt aus dem Gespräch heraus hervorgeht, sondern was verrät über die Persönlichkeit des Autors. Also irgendwie, ja, also ein Geheimnis im Prinzip, was man sich vielleicht noch erarbeitet dann und in so einem Text unterbringen kann. Also so würde ich, würde ich es eher sehen als dieses absolute Interesse an der Persönlichkeit. Das mag sich jetzt auch geändert haben, nochmal wegen TikTok. Ich weiß nicht, wie Caroline Wahl, ob die auf TikTok ihre Persönlichkeit, ihren persönlichen Background so zur Schau stellt.
Also ich persönlich, mich interessiert das Buch, der Roman. Natürlich interessiert mich auch irgendwie, wer das geschrieben hat. Aber ich lese jetzt nicht, wenn ich habe jetzt was von der Autorin gelesen, das heißt Kleine Monster. Das könntest du dir auch mal durchlesen. Da geht es um eine Familie, die haben ein Kind und dieses Kind ist sieben Jahre alt und geht in die Schule und auch einmal kommt ein Ruf die Schule an bei den Eltern und sagt, da ist was vorgefallen. Und dieses Kind, ein Junge, hat offenbar sein Penis einer Mitschülerin gezeigt, als sie zu zweit im Raum waren. Und dann geht es die ganze Zeit, und das ist wirklich sehr gut so psychologisch gemacht. Also diese Entfremdung von dem eigenen Kind. Kenn ich mein Kind, lüft mich mein Kind an. Was passiert da eigentlich auch innerhalb der Familie? Es ist wirklich ein sehr gutes Buch und hat so eine interessante Dynamik. Also mich interessiert, Jessica Lindh heißt die, aber ich weiß nichts über sie. Ich glaube, weiß ich nicht, irgendwie in den 80er Jahren geboren. Aber es interessiert mich nicht so. Ich weiß aber, dass natürlich jetzt, so als Caroline Wahl angesprochen, die ist ja seit Wochen wieder auf der Bestsellerliste mit ihrem Buch Windstärke 17 und 22 Bahnen. Das kennen hier wahrscheinlich auch viele. Da ist man letztes Jahr quasi kaum drum rumgekommen, wenn man mal auf die Spiegel Bestsellerliste gesehen hat. Und die natürlich bedient auch dieses Programm. Ich habe die letztes Jahr mal getroffen. Die hat unglaublich viele Lesungen gemacht. Ich weiß nicht, wann sie den Fortsetzungsroman geschrieben hat. Ich glaube, zwischen all diesen Lesungen und diese ganze TikTok-Industrie. Und es ist ja eine Industrie. Also zum Beispiel hat der Verlag, um dieses Buch zu promoten, für TikTokker so richtige Päckchen gepackt. In diesen Päckchen waren, glaube ich, ich weiß es jetzt nicht mehr ganz genau, aber irgendwelche Lebensmittel, die in dem Buch vorkommen zum Beispiel. Und das ist ein Buch zum Beispiel, das über TikTok richtig Fahrt aufgenommen hat. Und darauf hat sich dann auch das Marketing total spezialisiert. Also klar, es gibt dann auch diese Autoren, die sehr in bestimmten sozialen Kanälen sehr präsent sind. Und andere wiederum, die, ich weiß gar nicht, ich glaube, mir fällt der Name jetzt nicht ein, aber es ist auch eine sehr gute, die möchte nicht mal, dass eine Kamera läuft, wenn sie eine Lesung macht. Judith Herrmann ist es, glaube ich. Die möchte nicht, dass eine Lesung von ihr gefilmt wird.
Ja, leicht peripher dazu. Ihr seid ja nun beide, wir verraten nicht so viel, selber gerade am Roman schreiben.
Nö.
No comment.
Okay, wir verraten also nichts, aber...
Wir fragen nächstes Jahr nochmal nach.
Gut, ich sage, ihr habt ja nun auch Erfahrungen mit eigenem fiktionalen Schreiben, in welcher Form auch immer. Verändert das eigentlich das Lesen? Denn ich weiß noch, als Kind, man glaubt ja dem Text alles. Also wird was vorgelesen und das ist nun so passiert, wenn auch man nicht genau weiß, in welcher Welt und so. Wenn man ein Sachbuch-Leser ist und dann schreibt man sein erstes Sachbuch und danach liest man wieder andere Sachbücher, ist man so ein bisschen entzaubert, würde ich sagen. Also man versteht so ein bisschen, dass dieses Buch nicht perfekt ist. Dass die Kapitelfolge auch anders, also sogar besser hätte sein können, wenn man nur mal mich gefragt hätte oder wie auch immer. Die eine oder andere Formulierung passt dann nicht so ganz. Die hätte man auch gerne besser. Und das kann ich mir eigentlich beim Roman auch vorstellen.
Oder umgekehrt, man stellt fest, dass es besonders konstruiert ist und man es gar nicht so künstlerisch mehr findet, oder umgedreht.
Aber dass man auf jeden Fall den Manufakturwert eines Romans, der einen eigentlich verzaubern will, nicht mehr so glaubt, weil man sich selber plötzlich schreibend am Tisch sitzen sieht, der dieses Buch gerade verfasst. Also man kriegt den Verfasser dann doch nicht ganz rausgezaubert. Aber ich habe wirklich keinen Roman geschrieben.
Ich verstehe es nicht richtig. Ich erkläre nochmal. Ich weiß nicht, was meinst du?
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, also in dem Moment, wenn Menschen zum ersten Mal gesehen haben, wie Fernsehen funktioniert. Also wenn sie einfach sehen, wie ein Kameramann da sein Kram macht und der Ton, dann gucken die danach an das Fernsehen, weil sie dann mehr wissen, dass es hergestellt ist.
Aber jeder schreibt ja anders. Du kannst es ja gar nicht verallgemeinern. Jeder Autor, zum Beispiel. Vorhin ging es ja um Thomas Mann. Mich hat es gewundert, dass er morgens dann so schlecht gelaunt ist, weil er hat ja immer nur morgens auch geschrieben. Er ist ja ganz früh aufgestanden, hat dann morgens geschrieben und Katja hat sich um alles gekümmert und ihm den Rücken freigehalten. Der konnte nicht mal sein, wenn jemand in den Pacific Palisades kam und seine Anzüge zurückgebracht hat, wusste er nicht mal, wo das Geld ist, um den zu bezahlen. Also jeder schreibt ja auf eine ganz andere Art und Weise. Und Caroline Wahl zum Beispiel, die hat jetzt bei Instagram, hat sie jetzt irgendwie gepostet, die ist jetzt mit dem Wohnwagen in Holland unterwegs und schreibt, ah, alle sagen, doch Roman schreiben sei so schwierig, der zweite das Schwierigste oder das Dritte. Und dann schreibt sie so, hihi, bei mir ist aber alles ganz leicht.
Also das fände ich gut, wenn es so ist. Also wenn ein das eigene Schreiben nicht entzaubert von dem Schreiben der anderen, sondern man sich dann genauso rein vertiefen kann in eben ausgedachte Wirklichkeiten, die man dann aber auch als wahrhaftig weiterhin annimmt, statt einfach zu sagen, oh ja, ist aber auch ein ganz gut, gut geschriebenes Buch.
Ich finde Schreiben irrsinnig anstrengend, aber egal ob fiktionales Schreiben oder anderes Schreiben, ich schreibe auch ungern in dem Sinne, dass ich mich richtig quälen muss zu schreiben. Ich mache es dann, glaube ich, recht gut und musste auch jetzt erkennen, als ich das Kinderbuch mit Ole geschrieben habe, dass mir das sehr viel leichter gefallen ist, dass ich mich mal nicht auf schon irgendwas beziehen musste in dem Sinne, dass ich sage, was hat dann der und der dazu gesagt und was muss ich noch von dem Regisseur kennen, um den Film zu bewerten oder so, sondern dass ich mir eine Welt ausdenke, dann gemeinsam mit Ode. Aber dennoch ist der Akt des Schreibens für mich schon ein ungeheurer Kraftakt. Ich lese lieber, als ich schreibe in dem Sinne. Und Abi Warburg hat ja mal gesagt, würden die Leute mehr lesen, dann würde vielleicht auch ein bisschen weniger geschrieben werden, was ganz gut wäre. Und das stimmt für vieles. Aber jetzt haben wir schon Booktalk angesprochen. Mich würde interessieren, wer ist schon mal einer Empfehlung, einer Buchempfehlung gefolgt, die von TikTok kam? Das sind ganz, ganz wenige, die sich melden. Und das ist interessant, denn die Buchhandlungen spiegeln ja was völlig anderes jetzt wieder. Da haben wir große Tische mit dem Hashtag Booktalk, also Bücher, die dort gehypt wurden. Oft nicht von den Verlagen, die jetzt zum Beispiel bei einem deutschen Buchpreis besonders bedacht werden, sondern eher das sehr populäre, früher hätte man vielleicht auch Groschenromanen haftet, dazu gesagt, das ist jetzt etwas, was wahnsinnig in den Fokus rückt, Verfilmungen erfährt und auch die Bestsellerlisten dominiert, was es dann auch für die, sagen wir, etwas anspruchsvollere Literatur sehr viel schwieriger macht, überhaupt da noch vorzukommen in diesem ach so lauten Booktalk. Oder wir haben das jetzt auch beim Kinderbuch gesehen, was es doch alles braucht, um überhaupt mal im stationären Buchhandel vertreten zu sein, obwohl man dann schon bei so einem Verlagvisurkampf ist. Seht ihr das auch als eine eigenartige Veränderung, dass sich also diese neue Literaturwelt völlig abgekoppelt hat von dem, was primär zum Beispiel bei der SWR besten Liste oder in der FAZ oder sonst wovorkommt?
Ja, in die Richtung scheint es zu gehen. Aber darf ich noch kurz eine andere Frage ans Publikum stellen? Wer lässt sich denn von seinen Freunden dazu animieren, Bücher zu lesen? Weil das scheint mir auch immer noch der gängige Weg zu sein.
So eine deutliche Mehrheit, ja.
Das ist interessant, da steckt ja so eine soziale Komponente drin. Also Booktalk ist ja das eine. Es gibt einen anderen Trend.
Ganz kurz noch diese Frage. Ich finde das schon interessant. Ich glaube schon, dass es sich so ein bisschen entkoppelt von der SWR besten Liste oder vielleicht auch von dem klassisch-phyrtonistischen Rezensionswesen, weil die Verlage natürlich auch, man muss ja auch nur mal die Spiegel Westseller-Liste angucken, was da so drauf steht, dieses ganze Wach-Flamm-Geküsst-Wach-Geküsst oder ich weiß gar nicht, wie diese ganzen Bücher heißen, auch mit diesen lustigen Covern. Das sind ja Bücher von Autoren, die wir jetzt, also die ich jetzt nicht so kenne und die ich auch nicht lese, aber die bei Jugendlichen oder jungen Erwachsenen einfach auch sehr beliebt sind und sehr stark gekauft werden. Und die Verlage gehen immer mehr auf. Die suchen sich durch die Querfinanzierung den einen mega Bestseller. Also wenn Caroline Wahl ihren Fortsetzungsroman schreibt, dann ist irgendwie klar, so, das war völlig klar, die wird wieder die Bestsellerliste anführen und das wird wieder ein paar Wochen so sein. Und dadurch wird dann einiges andere auch mitfinanziert. Aber diese Bücher, die wir früher zum Beispiel, ich finde ein gutes Beispiel, Daniel Kehlmann, der einen unfassbaren Vorschuss bekommen haben muss. Ich habe Zahlen gehört, da ist mir irgendwie ganz schwindlig geworden. Und ich habe mal verfolgt, wie lang der auf dieser Liste stand. Ich glaube nicht, dass der dieses, ich weiß es nicht, aber ich glaube nicht, dass er dieses Geld wieder reingespielt hat. Aber trotzdem ist er eben so wichtig auch als Name, dass man ihn unbedingt halten wollte, weil es von den großen Namen natürlich auch viele gibt, die dann immer wieder auch zu anderen Verlagen gehen. Aber es hat sich schon, da hat sich deutlich was verändert. Also ich glaube, vor zehn Jahren kannten wahrscheinlich die meisten hier mehr Namen, wenn sie ihnen auf den besterletzten begegnet sind, als heute. Es sind ja auch ganz viele Krimis, die dort jetzt stehen. Irgendwie unser, wie heißt der? Ja, genau Fidzek.
Was wir zum Beispiel auch beobachten, ist, dass Bücher, die schon vor Jahren publiziert wurden und jetzt über TikTok wieder sozusagen in die Öffentlichkeit geschwemmt werden, dass die dann Jahre später noch rezensiert werden von den bekannten, also Deutschlandfunk und so weiter. Also teilweise ist da so ein praktischen Wechsel in der Aufmerksamkeitspolitik entstanden, dass man eben, dass sie sich durchaus daran mehr ausrichten. Und wir hatten zu Beginn der Leipziger Buchmesse auch einen Aufmacher bei uns in der Sonntagszeitung von Kollegen in der SONT, also von der FAS, der auch ausführlich über diese TikTok-Phänomene geschrieben hat. Also da ist man schon, das Interesse ist schon sehr groß daran und die, vielleicht auch, ist auch ein bisschen Angst da, was verändert sich da. Aber ich meine, ich würde immer sagen, dass es was, was positives ist, weil die Alternativen für Kinder, ich war jetzt gerade mit Kindern im Urlaub, was anderes zu machen, sind so gigantisch. Also es ist klar, dass die keinen Bock haben, ein Buch zu öffnen und dann ist es doch umso besser, wenn sie über TikTok dazu animiert werden, als wenn sie von ihren Eltern gezwungen werden müssen oder halt gar nicht damit anfangen.
Ja, ein Lesepublikum zu finden, unabhängig davon, ob das Buch jetzt gerade neu ist. Also das ist ja die alte Rezensionsgeschichte, dass man es immer über die Neuerscheinung dreht. Jetzt kommt es wahrscheinlich über, was habe ich denn noch im Regal und könnte ja mal lesen und darüber noch mal einen Trend an einem Buch kleben, das vielleicht schon so ein paar Jahre alt ist. Aber manchmal werden ja Bücher auch aktuell durch Zeitgeist oder was auch immer, was gerade so passiert. Ihr habt ja auch JD Vans jetzt besprochen. Das ist ein Buch von 2017. Das ist jetzt gerade plötzlich aktuell, weil es jetzt so vielsagend ist. Damals hat es halt einfach nur das Milieu beschrieben und heute ist es plötzlich so eine politische Geschichte. Also da kommt ja auch viel mit.
Aber durch die Fokussierung auf diese mega Bestseller, das hattet ihr ja in eurem Podcast auch schon thematisiert, dass eben gigantische Vorschüsse an bestimmte Autoren gezahlt werden, und indem man eben hofft, dass es entweder die, die sich schon sehr gut verkauft haben, eine Fortsetzung schreiben oder sehr prominente Namen. Das hat natürlich für all die anderen Autoren zur Folge, dass die viel weniger bekommen, viel weniger Marketing, viel weniger Aufmerksamkeit, weniger Vorschüsse. Ich glaube, 99 Prozent der Leute, die Romane schreiben, können ja auch gar nicht davon leben. Das sind ja nur ganz, ganz, ganz wenige. Und es werden auch immer wenige und wie leider sonst auch geht, auch hier die Schere auseinander. Die werden immer mehr verdienen und zwar richtig gut verdienen. Und die anderen werden langsam irgendwie ausgeblutet werden. Und was schadet es, weil ich glaube schon, dass dann vielleicht auf Dauer so eine bestimmte Vielfalt verloren geht, auch wenn man an experimentelle Literatur denkt. Man muss sich das ja auch leisten können oder man möchte es sich leisten, auch als Verlag. Aber ich glaube, der Wille wird dann auch immer weniger, wenn man auf das Ökonomische einfach nur guckt und sagt, lohnt es sich eigentlich, sich für dieses Buch jetzt die große Marketingkampagne zu starten?
Ein Weg, den Longtail aufzuschlüsseln, ist ja, alle lesen einfach mehr. Dann werden auch mehr Bücher, dann ist wieder mehr los im Markt. Ich habe hier einen Trend gefunden, den ich sehr gut finde. Ich muss, glaube ich, nicht rätseln. Ihr nicht so. Ich bin gespannt, was ihr dazu sagt.
Hast du schon mal was von einem Silent Book Club gehört? Bei einem Silent Book Club wird sich zum Beispiel in einem Café getroffen und gemeinsam gelesen. Also jeder für sich, das, was er oder sie gerne lesen möchte. Später gibt es dann die Möglichkeit zum Austausch, aber kein Zwang, man kann auch einfach nur zuhören. Der allererste wurde 2012 in San Francisco von zwei Freundinnen ins Leben gerufen. Ich...
Ja, blablabla. Also man trifft sich und liest einfach. Es sieht dann so aus.
Aber da strickt einer die Liste dann.
Man darf auch stricken, das heißt, es ist nicht ein...
Warum wird die nicht rausgeschmissen?
Und die Hintergrundmusik ist auch dabei, oder?
Ja, die Hintergrundmusik beim Lesen, das kann ich also gar nicht vertragen, da werd ich sehr sauer.
Wahrscheinlich ist es dort leise, ihr wisst ja wie es ist, es ist ein Instagram-Video für euch.
Das gefällt dir, Stefan. Aber du liest doch gar nicht, was gefällt dir daran?
Na ja, ich bin der, guck mal, die Sexen hier so da.
Ich muss dir ein bisschen erklären, weil das sich überhaupt, das leuchtet einem ja erst mal nicht ein. Also unter Buchclub versteht man ja eigentlich, dass Menschen sich verabreden, ein Buch zu lesen, gelesen zu haben. Und dann kommen sie zusammen und diskutieren darüber.
Wäre das auch ganz schrecklich?
Mag sein, weiß ich nicht.
Ist ein so ein besser Witzertreffen.
Ich hab ja mein Buchclub mit Stefan. Und da sind natürlich manche Aufnahmen ganz schön hart für mich.
Und redet ihr dann immer über Krabat?
Stefan hat ja nicht gelesen, du kannst ja dann frei reden.
Aber dies ist ja ein Club, in dem man sich trifft, um eine Stunde oder länger. Ich hab mal geguckt für Deutschland, da sind viele Sachen, die angeboten werden. Man sitzt eine Stunde still da, liest das Buch, das man lesen möchte. Das heißt nicht lesen alle ein Buch, sondern jeder liest das Buch, das sie mitbringen. Und anschließend ist noch so ein bisschen get together. Und man kann natürlich über Literatur reden, muss aber nicht, kann doch irgendwas anderes machen.
Genau.
Also das ist das Konzept. Das heißt, was hier eigentlich angeboten wird, ist eine Stunde ohne Smartphone zu sein und in Gesellschaft, die potenziell auch an Literatur interessiert ist.
Ja, also sie beschreibt uns das nochmal kurz, denn dieser zweite Teil gehört da durchaus dazu. Also der Talk, der anschließende gehört dazu. Man hat sich aber nicht auf eine Literatur geeinigt, sondern jeder wirft dann so ein bisschen ein. Und es ist auch nicht eine gemeinsame große Runde, sondern man sitzt halt zufällig mit jemandem am Tisch und dann gibt es vielleicht so ein Signal oder so, keine Ahnung, das Lesen ist jetzt vorbei. Jeder darf jetzt reden, ohne jemanden zu stören, meine ich damit, so und dann geht es los.
Für mich wäre es nicht so was, ich mochte schon nie das Lesen der Bibliothek. Ich bin immer derjenige, der in die Bibliothek reingerannt ist. Das Buch ausgeliehen hat oder am besten ganz kopiert hat und dann mit nach Hause geschleppt hat und dort gelesen, weil mich dann doch vieles stört. Allerdings finde ich eigentlich diesen Ansatz nicht ganz dumm, denn es ist ja dadurch, dass die Literatur nicht mehr so wichtig ist, nicht mehr so primär im Zentrum steht, heute nicht so einfach möglich, in einer Kneipe zu sitzen und zu sagen, und was hast du gelesen? Dann würde ich vielleicht sagen, ja vor zehn Jahren Dave Eggers oder so. Und dann wird es schwierig, die Kommunikation zu kommen. Aber wenn ich jetzt habe, jemand, der gerade auch liest, und ich habe auch gerade gelesen, dann ist es vielleicht erst einmal egal, dass das unterschiedliche Bücher waren, sondern man kann ja dann sehr schnell dazu kommen, ja, was gefällt einem eigentlich generell oder gibt sich Empfehlung und kommt darüber hinaus in ein Gespräch, das in irgendeiner Weise interessant ist, und das kann sich ja dann noch etwas von der Literatur lösen. Oder wie seht ihr das?
Ja, es geht doch ums Kennenlernen anderer Leute, die da auch lesen, oder?
Bisschen Dating auch, ja.
Ja, ein bisschen so, ja. Es gibt ja auch bei Tinder, dass die Leute irgendwie angeben, welche Literatur sie bevorzugen und dann nur anhand dessen auswählen.
Die einen leihen sich einen Hund, die anderen nehmen ein Buch.
Außerdem ein bisschen soziale Kontrolle, man kann das Buch nicht ständig weglegen und aufs Handy schauen.
Das stimmt, also die No-Phone-Sachen.
Vielleicht solltest du das mal ausprobieren.
Das ist hier ganz wichtig. Sollte man das dem Literaturs mal vorschlagen, dass ein Tag im Monat Silent Book Club ist hier in Frankfurt?
Vorschreiben ist immer gut, ja.
Ich finde, sowas sollte man irgendwie machen. Es gibt aber noch einen zweiten Silent Trend. Wir haben ja eben schon über Booktalk gesprochen. Es gibt auch Menschen, die Silent Reviews machen. Das sieht dann so aus.
Es werden nur die Buchcover eingeblendet und dann werden quasi Emojis selbst hergestellt, um zu sagen, war funny, war...
Das hätte ich in der Buchpreisjury super gefunden. Das wäre super gewesen.
Ja.
Vor allem sieht man...
Mega!
Die Leute lesen wirklich sehr viel. Hier kommen ja, jeder hat ja zehn Bücher hier am Start.
Vielleicht sollten wir das mal bei FAZ net ausprobieren.
Ich find's super.
Ja, ich möchte euch da sehen, wie ihr Emojis macht. Ihr müsst allerdings auch wahrscheinlich dann den Roman von Colin Hoover lesen. Viel Spaß dabei. Also die Literatur ist noch zu retten. Das Lesen muss noch mal neu gelernt werden. Oder man muss eigentlich, um es ganz klar auszusprechen, dieses verdammte Smartphone am besten wegschließen für eine Weile und dann sich dem Buch widmen. Und dann kann man ja nachher zurück zum Smartphone gehen. Und vielleicht setzt dann ein, dass man das, was dort alles einem Fall geboten wird, nicht mehr so als wichtig empfindet, weil man doch in einer ganz anderen Tiefe unterwegs war, wenn man gelesen hat.
Genau, wie hat der Papst gesagt, man trifft dafür keine Entscheidungen, die man später bereut, wenn man liest. Das finde ich auch einen guten Ansatz.
Ja, das ist wirklich sehr gut.
Ich habe noch einen Clip, den wollte ich mal spielen. Wir sind mit diesem Reden heute über die Oper und über Bücher ganz weit weg von Politik. Wir sind aber eigentlich ein politischer Podcast. Nächste Woche haben wir wieder Podcasts. Er wird wieder sehr politisch. Wie immer, es wird uns eine Sache davor retten, dass tatsächlich die Welt von Donald Trump regiert wird. Er liest einfach nicht. Wir haben hier Bill O'Reilly, der hat ja lange die Fox-News-Geschäfte geführt, damit auch dieses Intrigen-Spinnennetz-Zentrale-Gewebe aufgemacht, in dem sich dann alle verfangen haben, inklusive Donald Trump und alle seine Jünger. Aber er wird darüber stolpern, dass er einfach den Lektürempfehlungen nicht gefolgt ist. Wäre er ein Reader, würde er das verstehen. Den Zeitgeist von damals, Churchill hat irgendwie so 4000 Seiten tagebuchartig oder so hinterlassen, ich hab keine Ahnung, die liegen jedenfalls bereit. Er hat gesagt, liest das, dann gelingt es dir. Und er folgt einfach diesem Ratschlag nicht. Und das rettet die Welt. Nicht zu lesen. Das Nicht-Lesen rettet die Welt.
Ich bin sehr gespannt darauf. Wir müssen uns ja dann auch auf heiße Tage einstellen. Du bist immer noch im Kamala-Harris-Hype, befürchte ich.
Nein, ich war nicht mehr in der Harris-Hype.
Ach so, okay, dann sprechen wir darüber.
Wolfgang glaubt immer noch, es gibt mehr als zwei Alternativen. Aber egal, wie man es aufzieht, egal, wie komplex man ist, denken möchte, egal, wie viele Ideologien man rauslesen möchte, Harris oder Trump, mehr ist es nicht.
Ja, und wer diese Binarität durchbrechen will, der geht dann vielleicht doch lieber zur Literatur über. Vielen Dank, Elena Witzeck, vielen Dank, Melanie Mühl.
Vielen Dank.
Übrigens gibt es zu diesem Clip noch ein Counterpart.
Ist es nicht lustig, wenn du so etwas wie Ich unterstütze öffentliche Bibliotheken sagst.
Die einen lesen, die anderen nicht.
Ja, sehr gut.
Komplizierter ist es nicht.
Ich darf noch einen letzten Clip von mir zeigen. Als ich mich mit diesen Tagebüchern auseinandersetzte, habe ich etwas dann gefunden, dass es Vincent hilft auch in allen Lebenslagen. Zum Beispiel Steigerungen von Testosteron oder wie kann man so früh wie möglich aufstehen? Und er hat jetzt hier noch mal so einen Lesetipp, den ich bitte nicht zu beherzigen.
Jedenfalls, ich heiße Vincent. Und mein Ziel ist es, anderen Leuten auf Self-Improvement zu helfen. Und ich rede einfach ein bisschen darüber, was in meinem Leben passiert ist und gebe einfach Tabs. Und wenn du Lust hast, dann kannst du ein Abo dalassen. Jedenfalls, was möchte ich dir sagen in diesem Video heute? Du musst Bücher lesen wie YouTube-Videos. Lest Bücher genauso, wie wenn du ein YouTube-Video schauen würdest. Guck mal, es ist so schwarz von stinklangweilig. Es gibt halt so Stellen, die halt einfach stinklangweilig sind. Und das machst du bei YouTube-Videos. Du tust dann 10, 20, sogar 30 Sekunden nach vorne spulen. Und warum macht man das genau das gleiche bei Büchern auch? Also man muss eigentlich genau das gleiche bei Büchern auch machen.
Ja, nun gab es, als ich gestern diesen Clipschnitt, eine neue Studie, die auch von der FAZ aufgegriffen wurde kurz, nämlich hat die Universität in Toronto eine Studie durchgeführt, was ist eigentlich mit dem Glückszustand bei den Leuten, die genau das machen jetzt nicht mit Büchern, sondern die skippen, die also vorspulen, die schnell weitergehen, die also sich nicht das YouTube-Video zu Ende ansehen. Sie sind unglücklicher danach, wie die, die sich dem ausgesetzt haben, obwohl es ihnen nicht gefallen hat. Das heißt also, die Vertiefung mit dem, was man nicht mag, kann einen am Ende glücklicher machen, als einfach nur immer weiter wischen, swipen, swipen, swipen. Und ich hatte dann ein interessantes Erlebnis. Gestern Abend war ich in Blink Twice, einem Film von Zoe Kravitz, der nicht besonders gut ist. Und ich hatte tatsächlich, weil ich dachte, ah morgen ist ja auch hier in Frankfurt was los, so dieses Bedürfnis jetzt nicht nur vorzuspulen, das geht im Kino nicht, sondern rauszugehen. Und ich bin generell nicht dagegen, das zu tun. Aber ich bin rausgegangen erst und dachte, nee, ich gehe jetzt wieder rein, habe mich hingesetzt und habe mir den Film ganz gegeben und habe sehr viel über das Kino nachgedacht, konnte dann eine Filmanalyse machen und war am Ende doch froh, auch das Schlechte gesehen zu haben. Das heißt, manchmal muss man sich zusammenreißen und dann erfährt man doch noch was Interessantes.
Deutet ja jetzt für mich, dass ich all die Bücher, die ich nicht gelesen habe, wirklich auch noch zu Ende lesen muss.
Das ist das große Anliegen. Wir werden das natürlich im Podcast weiterverfolgen. Vielen Dank an euch alle und bis zum Ende des Monats dann.
Yes, nächste Woche.